HAVING A VERY INTERESTING
INFORMATIONAL HEARING TODAY ON
THE TOPIC OF PLASTICS.
IN OUR OCEANS.
AND I WANT TO FIRST START BY
EXTENDING MY THANK YOU AND MY MY
GRATITUDE TO UNDERSTAND WHO'S.
I HERE --
BUT HE'LL BE BACK IN IN HIS
COMMITTEE STAFFERS WORK VERY
CLOSELY WITH OUR COMMITTEE STAFF.
I IN PUTTING TOGETHER THIS VERY
IMPORTANT HEARING.
WE ARE.
LITERALLY SURROUNDED.
BY PLUS I JUST EXTEND MY THANKS
AND GRATITUDE TO YOU.
ARCHER STERN AND WHEN WE GIVE
MAKE SURE THAT HE'S GOT A SEE
HERE AT THE FRONT --
ITSELF.
OKAY WE'RE SURROUNDED BY PLASTIC
IT'S AN ALMOST EVERYTHING THAT --
WHICH WE INTERACT.
OFFERS BACK RIGHT HERE.
FIRST INTRODUCED IN THE
NINETEENTH CENTURY PLASTIC
QUICKLY GAINED POPULARITY
BECAUSE OF IT'S DURABILITY ITS
IT'S IT'S THE FACT IS LIGHT
WEIGHT.
THE FACT THAT CAN BE EASILY
MOLDED INTO DIFFERENT SHAPES AND
AND SIZES AND AND AND FIT ALL
SORTS OF DIFFERENT PRODUCTS.
AND SO --
BUT IT IS EVEN IN THE GRAND
SCHEME OF HUMAN HISTORY OF
RELATIVELY RECENT PHENOMENON.
AND BY THE MID NINETEEN SIXTIES
FIFTEEN MILLION TONS.
OF PLASTIC WASTE WERE PRODUCED
EVERY YEAR SO THE MID SIXTIES
FIFTEEN MILLION TONS.
NOW THE ANNUAL TOTAL IS NEARLY
THIRTY TIMES GREATER WE'RE
ALMOST AT FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION TIMES.
AND THE SAD TRUTH IS THAT OUT OF
ALL THE PLASTIC EVER CREATED ON
PLANET EARTH ONLY 9%.
I HAS BEEN RECYCLED 12% IS BEEN
BURNED INCINERATED WHICH OF
COURSE IS A VERY DANGEROUS THING.
I GIVEN THE PRODUCTS IN PLASTIC.
AND THEN THE REMAINING SEVENTY
NINE PER IN OUR LANDFILLS IT'S
IN OUR ENVIRONMENT.
AS LITTER --
AND FORCING MUCH MORE OF IT IS
ACTUALLY IN LITTER GLOBALLY AND
THAN IN LANDFILLS --
IS ESTIMATED AT EIGHT MILLION
METRIC TONS OF PLASTICS AND UP
IN THE OCEANS EVERY YEAR.
AND THE CONCERN IS THAT IF THE
PRESENT TRENDS CONTINUE BY
TWENTY FIFTY IT'S ESTIMATED THAT
THERE WILL BE TWELVE BILLION
METRIC TONS OF PLASTIC IN OUR
LANDFILLS. ONE OF BIG CHALLENGES
WHAT YOU KNOW WHY IS THIS A
PROBLEM ONE OF THE BIG PROBLEMS
IS OF COURSE THAT THAT
DURABILITY THAT MAKES IT SO
USEFUL.
FOR THE PRODUCTS THAT WE HAVE --
A ALSO MAKES IT SO DIFFICULT FOR
CLASSIC ABOUT A GREAT RIGHT IT
IS VERY SLOWLY BREAKS DOWN INTO
MICRO PLASTICS.
WHICH ARE THEN INGESTED BY FISH
AND OTHER MARINE ANIMALS.
MICHAEL PLASTICS ARE FOUND ALL
THROUGHOUT OUR OCEANS ARE FRESH
WATER ECOSYSTEMS ARE SOIL OUR
AIR.
RECENT STUDIES OF ACTUALLY
FOUNDED IN.
BOTTLED WATER --
AND WE KNOW NOW THAT WE'RE ON
TRACK TO HAVING MORE PLASTIC IN
OUR OCEAN THAN FISH --
WITHIN WITHIN THE NEXT DECADE OR
TWO NO WERE ALSO FAMILIAR WITH
SOME OF THE MOST DRAMATIC IMAGES
THAT HAVE BEEN BROUGHT TO US BY
NATIONAL GEOGRAPHIC AND OTHERS
THERE IS THE FAMOUS.
VIDEO OF THAT SEA TURTLE WITH A
PLASTIC STRAW STUCK INTO ITS
NOSE WE'VE SEEN PHOTOGRAPHS OF
MARINE ANIMALS MISTAKING PLASTIC
BAGS FOR JELLY FISH --
THERE WAS OF JUST A BEAUTIFUL
BUT SERENE STRANGE.
IMAGES THAT THEY CAME OUT FOR
NATIONAL GEOGRAPHIC IN THEIR
SPECIAL ADDITION A CUP OF LAST
YEAR.
AND THE SLIDE THAT WE SEE HERE
IS JUST THE LATEST THIS
LITERALLY IS FROM YESTERDAY.
OUR TWO DAYS AGO JUST THIS LAST
FRIDAY THE PHILIPPINES BUREAU OF
FISHERIES AND AQUATIC RESOURCES
FOUND A YOUNG WELL THAT WAS WEAK
AND VOMITING BLOOD.
THE ANIMAL PASSED WITHIN A FEW
HOURS IN A THEY SAID WELL WHAT'S
WHAT'S THE DEAL HERE WHAT'S
GOING ON WITH THIS WELL THEY
OPEN UP THE WHALE.
AND IT WAS EXTRAORDINARY IN THIS
ONE TO HAVE ALL THAT WAS
SWIMMING OFF THE COAST THEY
FOUND EIGHTY EIGHT POUNDS OF
PLASTIC --
INCLUDING SIXTEEN RICE SACKS IN
PLASTIC BAGS.
SO YEAH THIS IS JUST A ONE
LITTLE EXAMPLE THIS IS ONE
LITTLE EXAMPLE OF THE PROBLEM
THAT WE HAVE OUT IN OUR OCEANS
RIGHT NOW.
AND WE'RE GONNA BE LEARNING A
LOT ABOUT THIS ISSUE WE'RE GONNA
BE LEARNING ABOUT THE PLASTIC
POLLUTION IN GENERAL WE'RE GONNA
LEARN ABOUT WHAT CAN BE DONE
WILL BE FIRST HEARING.
WE HAVE SEVERAL PANELS THE FIRST
PANEL I WILL BE GIVING IN IN --
OVERVIEW OF CLASSIC POLLUTION WE
HAVE A DEBRA HOWEVER STATUS THE
SECOND RECTOR OF THE OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNCIL.
AND DOCTOR CLEAR STEEL WITH THIS
IS A PROFESSOR FOR FROM OUR CAL
STATE CHANNEL ISLANDS CAMPUS
THEN WE'RE GONNA BE HEARING FROM --
DOCTOR JEFF.
POINT BONE BONE OKAY EXACTLY
DIRECTOR OF THE MARINE MAMMAL
CENTER --
WHO'S GOING TO BE DISCUSSING HOW
PLASTIC POLLUTION AS AFFECTED
OUR MARINE LIFE AND WILL ALSO BE
HEARING FROM.
MILLION CORD AND PROGRAM
DIRECTOR OF UPSTREAM WE WILL BE
TALKING ABOUT SOME OF THE
SUCCESSFUL LOCAL EFFORTS THAT
ARE OUT THERE ADDRESSING PLUS TO
PLASTIC POLLUTION --
AND AND HER ORGANIZATIONS BEEN
PART OF SO WE'LL BE LOOKING WILL
BE STARTING WITH AN OVERVIEW
THEN WE'LL BE LOOKING AT A LOCAL
EFFORTS IN THE IMPACT ON RE
WILDLIFE IT SHOULD IT SHOULD BE
A A VERY INFORMATIVE AND AND I
JUST HOPE IT'S GOING TO BE A
GOOD.
EXPERIENCE FOR ALL OF OUR
MEMBERS TO THE GET ARE THEIR
HEADS AROUND THIS IS VERY VERY
SERIOUS PROBLEM THAT WE FACE AS
A SOCIETY.
AND WITH THAT I'D LOVE TO PASS
THE MICROPHONE TO CENTER STERN
AND SEE IF ANY DO YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENTS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
[inaudible]
WHAT'S THE THE FAMOUS LINE IN
THE GRADUATE BUT THE FUTURE.
ALL RIGHT.
ADVISING A YOUNG PERSON ABOUT.
WHAT TO LOOK OFF SO HOW LITTLE
WE KNEW?
BACK THEN.
OUR FUTURE I THINK IS GOING TO
HAVE TO LOOK A LOT DIFFERET IF
WE'RE GOING TO ACTUALLY.
PUT OUR ECOSYSTEMS IN A PLACE TO
SURVIVE -- I
DON'T WANT TO BE THE LAST
GENERATION.
THAT.
CAN SURF IN AN OCEAN THAT.
AS LIFE IN IT --
THESE ARE TOUGH EXISTENTIAL
THINGS TO GET YOUR HEAD AROUND.
BUT THEY'RE HERE AND SO TODAY
WILL BE SOBERING.
IT'S A LIEU IT'S A LOT IT'LL BE
A DOWNER POTENTIALLY FOR THOSE
OF YOU HERE.
I KNOW YOU LIVE IN THIS WORLD SO
THINGS DO.
FEEL OVERWHELMING AT TIMES IN
TODAY'S REALLY GOING TO BE ABOUT
SCOPING THIS PROBLEM AND REALLY
JUST SOBERING UP.
THEN REALIZING THE SCALE OF WILL
GET A TAKE ON BUT I THINK YOU'RE
INCREDIBLE SIDES HOPE.
AROUND THE WORLD [inaudible]
I THINK.
OUR IT INNOVATION POWERS ARE
IMMENSE. TO SOLVE THIS ISSUE.
YOU SEE IN THE UK IN THE E. U..
INCREDIBLY DRAMATIC STEPS IT.
MULTI A STATE LEVEL OCCURRING
BUT ALSO ALL THE WAY DOWN.
TO LITTLE CITIES.
THEY JUST WANT.
TO LET THEIR KIDS GO IN THE
OCEAN AND ENDS AND HAVE SOME --
SOME SENSE THAT IT IT ACTUALLY
IS A LIVE IN IT IS FEEDING US
BECAUSE IT IT IS THE THE KEY TO
THIS PLANET SURVIVAL AND THE WAY
WE'RE TREATING IT RIGHT NOW IS
IS TRULY AS A LANDFILL.
SO I APPRECIATE BRING IN THIS --
THIS THIS SORT OF COASTAL UNITY
HERE --
FOLKS LIKE TO MAKE FUN OF THE
COASTAL REPRESENTATIVE IS IN
THIS LEGISLATURE SOMETIMES AND
SAY.
YOU KNOW THIS IS AN EXCEPTIONAL
IS THE ISSUE.
THAT THE COAST IS --
SOMETHING THAT IS ONLY FOR THE
EXCEPTIONAL FEW IN.
WE KNOW THAT THE VISION IS THAT.
THIS OCEAN IS CLOSEST FOR ALL IN
CALIFORNIA BY LAW.
AND HOPEFULLY BY OUR PRACTICES
AND OUR FUNDING IN OUR
PRIORITIES.
BUT I I WOULDN'T I WOULDN'T
HESITATE FOR ANY KID GROWING UP
STAY IN THE ENTIRE SOUTH LAND.
ROBIN I REALIZE WHAT ACTUALLY
HAPPENS WHEN YOU THROW SOMETHING
AWAY.
AND THINGS JUST DON'T GO AWAY.
AND THAT'S WHAT TODAY'S ABOUT
WHERE THEY GO SO THANK YOU.
GIVEN MISTER CHAIR.
AND IT'S TRUE YOU KNOW WITH THIS
BECAUSE REALLY DOES TO FIND
CALIFORNIANS SO MANY RESPECTS --
THOUGH I WILL SAY YOU BROUGHT UP
THE U. I I NOTICE YOU JUST
ARRIVE WE'RE ALSO GOING TO BE
HEARING FROM THE CONSUL GENERAL --
TO SERVICE --
THE ENTIRE WEST COAST ON BEHALF
OF THE GOVERNMENT OF AUSTRIA SO
ANDREAS LONERS A GOOD FRIEND AND
HE'S GOING TO BE BOB PRESENTING
AT THE BEGINNING A PUBLIC
COMMENT ON SOME OF THE
FASCINATING WORK THAT'S
HAPPENING IN EUROPE --
AND THE ZERO WASTE ACTIVITIES
HAPPENING IN THE CITY OF VIENNA
NOT A COASTAL COUNTRY.
OF COURSE AUSTRIA A MOUNTAINOUS
COUNTRY BUT ONE THAT I THINK HAS
TAKEN ITS ENVIRONMENTAL
STEWARDSHIP RESPONSIBILITIES
VERY SERIOUSLY.
AND HAS SOME SAYS SOME
INTERESTING LESSONS TO TEACH US
ABOUT WHAT --
WHAT WHAT IS HAPPENING IN IN A
VIBRANT CITY LIKE VIENNA ON THE
ISSUE OF WASTE REDUCTION?
AND SO WE'RE EXCITED TO HEAR
FROM HIM AS WELL --
SO OTHER OTHER COMMENTS SERVE OR
OPENING REMARKS MARK FROM
MEMBERS CENTER MONEY.
THANK YOU I JUST I JUST WANT TO
THANK THE CO CHAIRS FOR
CONVENING THIS I HADN'T PLANNED
TO SAY ANYTHING BUT WHEN YOU
MENTION THE SUBJECT MATTER
POTENTIALLY BEING A DOWNER --
YESTERDAY WAS OCEAN DAY LOBBY
DAY UP HERE.
AND A YOUNG WOMAN FROM HOLLISTER
IN SAN BENITO COUNTY SHELBY
O'NEILL WAS HERE SHE HAS
SPEARHEADED.
AN EFFORT TO GET RID OF PLASTIC
STRAWS IN THE POWER OF ONE
PERSON ORGANIZING --
SHE'S SUCCEEDED IN MANY CITIES
GETTING RID OF PLASTIC STRAWS --
AS WELL AS SUPPORTING
LEGISLATION LAST YEAR THAT NOW
REQUIRES YOU HAVE TO BE OFFERED
A STRAW --
YOU HAVE TO REQUEST A STRONG --
THEY'RE NOT AUTOMATICALLY
DISTRIBUTE WOMAN'S EFFORTS --
DELTA AIRLINES NO LONG NO LONGER.
PROVIDES PLASTIC STRAWS ON THEIR
FLIGHTS --
SO LITTLE BY LITTLE AND I KNOW
WE'LL HEAR OTHER STORIES OF
ACHIEVEMENT BUT THE DATA.
IS OVERWHELMING THE REALITY
PICTURES.
BEACHES IN THE DOMINICAN
REPUBLIC COVERED WAY EVERYWHERE
SET BRINGING IN [inaudible]
PLASTIC SO.
WE'RE KIND OF BEHIND THE CURVE I
APPRECIATE YOUR CONVENING THIS
AND IT'S UP TO US TO MAKE THE
DIFFERENCE.
THANK YOU VERY THE CHAIR AND I
WERE TO SWAY YOU EVENT LAST
NIGHT WHERE THEY HAD I COULDN'T
HELP BUT NOTICE ALL THE STRAWS
THAT THEY WERE USING WHERE WERE --
ENTIRELY BIODEGRADABLE AND IT
DIDN'T DETRACT AT ALL FROM
EVERYONE'S EXPERIENCE --
AND AND YOU KNOW.
BUT BY DOING WHAT WHAT WITH THAT
LEADERSHIP THAT YOU MENTION
WE'RE NOW THE SWANKY WITHOUT YOU
CAN BE TWENTY WITHOUT PLASTIC
ALRIGHT THERE YOU GO OKAY SO
LET'S --
LET'S START WITH OUR FIRST PANEL
AND WE'RE GONNA BE TALKING ABOUT --
PLASTIC POLLUTION FIRST WE HAVE
DEBRA HELPS OUT SO DEBORAH IS
EXACTLY DIRECTOR OF OUR OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNCILS HE'S ALSO
DEBBIE SECRETARY FOR OCEANS.
AND COASTAL PLANT A POLICY FOR
THE NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY AT
THE STATE.
HE HAS EXTENSIVE EXPERIENCE IN
ENVIRONMENTAL ON POLICY SHE
SPENT TEN YEARS AT THE OFFICE OF
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
LITIGATING CIVIL AND CRIMINAL
CASES TO ENFORCE OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL LAWS THAT I'M SURE
SHE HAS A PAINS ABOUT THE LAST
BILL WE JUST HEARD.
I RECEIVED HER JD MOST
IMPORTANTLY UC BERKELEY --
THE BEST LAW SCHOOL IN THE LAND.
AND UNFORTUNATELY RECEIVED ABOUT
OF ARTS OF STANFORD --
AND BEFORE LAW SCHOOL WOULD WORK
FOR GOVERNOR GRAY DAVIS ACTUALLY
HANDLING NATURAL RESOURCES
IMPROPER TECHNIQUE RESOURCES
ISSUES.
FANTASTIC PERSON WE'RE LOOKING
FOR TO YOUR TESTIMONY MS
HARBORSIDE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CHAIRMAN ALLEN
AND JACK CAM AND STERN FOR
INVITING ME AND OLIVES AND THE
SENATORS FOR HOSTING THIS VERY
IMPORTANT TOPIC.
AND I AM PLEASED TO BE HERE TO
TALK ABOUT THIS GORGE OF
PLASTICS IN OUR OCEANS TODAY.
AND AGAIN I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA FOR
PROTECTION COUNCIL OF YEAH LET
ME GET THE SLIDE.
CRITICISM OF THE THIS IS NOT
MINE.
YEAH YEAH.
EXIT INSISTING --
YEAH THERE AGAIN.
AN AGAIN I AM THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNSEL AND DEPUTY
SECRETARY EVERY RESOURCES AGENCY
FOR OCEAN AND COASTAL MATTERS.
AN IMPENDING FOR THIS TALK I
REFLECTED ON A AY I SPENT LAST
YEAR AT COASTAL CLEANUP AND WITH
MY FAMILY AND I WATCHED MY KIDS
DIGGING THROUGH THE SAND LOOKING
FOR THE LITTLE SHARDS OF GREEN
OR RED PLASTIC PIECES AND
PUTTING THEM IN THE POCKET.
AND PULLING UP THOSE ARM LOADS
OF WATER BOTTLES.
AND I THOUGHT ABOUT HOW SIMILAR
THEIR ACTIONS WORD TO YOUNG
TURTLES WERE YOUNG SEA LIONS ARE
YOUNG FISH.
HUNTING.
AND THE ONLY DIFFERENCE WAS MY
KIDS WHEN I THAT PLASTIC.
EVERY YEAR OUR SISTER AGENCY THE
COASTAL COMMISSION HOSTS AND
COASTAL CLEANUP DAY AND
VOLUNTEER SPREAD OUT ACROSS THE
BEACHES AND THE COAST. TO
COLLECT TRASH AND THEY COLLECT
OVER EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND
POUNDS OF TRASH IN A SINGLE DAY.
THIS IS A REALLY IMPRESSIVE
ACCOMPLISHMENT [inaudible]
UNFORTUNATELY EIGHTEEN BILLION
POUNDS OF PLASTIC OR EIGHT
MILLION METRIC TONS AND ENTER
THE OCEAN EVERY YEAR.
SO FROM HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
TONS OF GHOST FISHING GEAR
DERELICT FISHING GEAR FLOATING
OUT THERE. TO THE BILLIONS UPON
BILLIONS OF TINY PIECES OF
PLASTIC BETTER INGESTED BY EVERY
LEVEL OF THE FOOD WEB FROM THE
PLANK.
TEN ALL THE WAY UP TO THE BLUE
WHALES.
ALL OF THE BOTTLES AND STRIDES
AND CAPS AND RAPPERS AND LIVES
IN BETWEEN WE ARE ILLING OUR
OCEAN WITH PLASTIC [inaudible]
AND YOUR OTHERS SPEAKERS THEY'RE
GOING TO BE TALKING ABOUT THE
SIGNIFICANT IMPACTS OF PLASTIC
ON MARINE TO MARINE ECOSYSTEM ON
HUMAN HEALTH.
AND MARINE ANIMALS AND IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT PLASTIC
POLLUTION IS VERY EXPENSIVE A
CALIFORNIA LOCAL COMMUNITIES
SPEND OVER FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR.
CLEANING UP IN CONTROLLING
LITTER.
MICHAEL THIS MORNING IS TO
PROVIDE SOME CONTEXT AND SOME
FRAMING.
AND MAYBE A LITTLE HOPE I'M
AROUND WHAT THE STATE IS DOING
TO PROTECT TO ADDRESS THE
PROBLEM.
I HAVE MISSED THAT PICTURE BUT
HERE WE GOT.
THEY AND LAST YEAR IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THE CALIFORNIA OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNCIL ADOPTED A NEW
CALIFORNIA OCEAN LITTER STRATEGY
PREVENTION STRATEGY AND THIS WAS
A STRATEGY THAT WAS DEVELOPED
THROUGH A VERY EXTENSIVE --
STAKEHOLDER DRIVEN PROCESS
COLLABORATIVE --
THROUGH PUBLIC PARTICIPATION AND
THE IDEA OF IT IS TO PROVIDE A
ROADMAP FOR ACTIONS THE STATE
AND OUR PARTNERS CAN TAKE TO
ADDRESS PLASTIC POLLUTION IN THE
OCEAN OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL
YEARS.
ON THE STRATEGY CONTAINS THREE
PRIMARY PRIORITIES --
FOR PC THE FIRST IS TO DEAL
REFER TO A SOURCE REDUCTION THE
SECOND IS TO ADDRESS MICRO
PLASTICS A MICROFIBER.
AND THE THIRD IS TO ADDRESS
DERELICT FISHING YEAR
[inaudible]
AND THERE ARE A VARIETY OF WAYS
TO PREVENT LITTER FROM REACHING
THE OCEAN AND THE STATE HAS
REALLY SHOWN LEADERSHIP ON THIS
TOPIC IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND SKI
SEASON.
TWENTY SIXTEEN AND THE VOTERS
PASSED PROPOSITION SIXTY SEVEN
WHICH BANNED SINGLE USE PLASTIC
BAGS IN CALIFORNIA AND LAST YEAR
MAJORITY LEADER CALDERON
INTRODUCED AB --
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FOUR WHICH AGAIN
AND AS WAS MENTIONED EARLIER
REQUIRES STRIDES TO BE --
PROVIDED AT SIT DOWN RESTAURANTS
ONLY UPON REQUEST AND SENATOR
ALLEN INTRODUCED THIS IS THE
ANIMAL PACKAGING LEGISLATION
WHICH REQUIRES AN ALL FOOD
PACKAGING.
IN CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS AND
BEACHES AND OTHER STATE
FACILITIES TO BE REUSABLE
COMPOSTABLE OR RECYCLABLE.
AT NEW PC WE'RE ALSO WORKING ON
A VARIETY OF AND PROJECTS
INCLUDING FOR EXAMPLE FINDING
THE NEWPORT BAY TRASH WE'LL AND
WHICH IS GOING TO BE TAKING.
FLOATING TRASH AND DEBRIS IN SAN
DIEGO CREEK BEFORE IT ENTERS THE
UPPER NEWPORT BAY MARINE
PROTECTED AREA AND GETTING THAT
ALL THAT TRASH OUT OF THE WAY.
AND THE PROJECT WAS BASED ON THE
VERY SUCCESSFUL.
BALTIMORE MR TRASH WE'LL AND WHO
ACTUALLY REMOVES FIFTY THOUSAND
POUNDS OF TRASH A DAY.
AND I'M HAS THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS OF SOCIAL MEDIA
FOLLOWERS I MEAN IT'S BEEN
HUGELY SUCCESSFUL IN EDUCATING
THE PUBLIC ABOUT THE IMPACTS OF
TRASH AND WILD.
WILDLIFE WATER QUALITY AND HELP
REPLICATE THAT WITH OUR NEWPORT
BAY TRASH WILL WE ALSO FUNDED A
PROGRAM IN ALAMEDA --
TO HELP.
RESTAURANTS REDUCE THEIR
RELIANCE ON SINGLE USE PACKAGING
SO WE WE AND CURRENTLY THE
PROJECT HAS CERTIFIED FORTY SIX
RESTAURANTS TO BE RE THINK
DISPOSABLE.
AND CUMULATIVELY JUST THE
CHANGES MADE BY JUST TEN OF
THOSE RESTAURANTS ATTACK ONLY
TEN RESTAURANTS IN THE FORTY SIX
PILOT RESTAURANTS.
WE HAVE A LIMITED ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION PIECES OF SINGLE USE
DISPOSABLE FOOD WHERE PACKAGING
EVERY YEAR.
AND THEY'VE SAVED FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS EVERY YEAR SO
THERE'S SOME REAL.
AND PROJECTS YOU CAN DO ON THE
GROUND TO GET TO THIS ISSUE --
LOCALLY BUT ALL OF OUR PROJECTS
NEED TO BE THOUGHT ABOUT
SCALABLE HOW ARE WE GOING.
TO BRING THIS UP TO THE STATE
LEVEL AND AND HAVE AS
SIGNIFICANT AN IMPACT AS WE CAN.
IN TERMS OF MICRO PLASTICS AND
THIS IS THE SECOND PRONG OF OUR
PLASTIC STRATEGY AND SENATOR
PORTANTINO LAST YEAR INTRODUCED
SB TWELVE SIXTY THREE WHICH
REQUIRES --
PC TO DEVELOP A COMPREHENSIVE
MICRO PLASTIC STRATEGY SO WE ARE.
WORKING WITH SCIENTISTS FROM
AROUND THE WORLD SCALE AND THE
IMPACT OF MICRO PLASTICS ON
CALIFORNIA'S ENVIRONMENT AND OUR
MARINE ECOSYSTEM AND THEN TO
DEVELOP SOLUTIONS TO ADDRESS A
MICRO POSIT POLLUTION.
AND FINALLY WE'RE WORKING VERY
CLOSELY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
AND THE CALIFORNIA FISH AND GAME
COMMISSION. TO ENHANCE AND BEST
MANAGEMENT PRACTICES TO PREVENT
AND RECOVER AND LOST OR
ABANDONED FISHING GEAR AND
AQUACULTURE HERE.
WE DO NOT WORK ALONE OF COURSE
THAT -- PC
PART OF OUR MISSION ACTUALLY IS
TO COORDINATE WITH OUR PARTNER
WITH OUR SISTER AGENCIES --
TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE BEING
AFFECT AS EFFECTIVE AS POSSIBLE
AND THAT OUR EFFORTS ARE
COMPLIMENTING AND NOT
DUPLICATING ONE ANOTHER.
AND SO CALIFORNIA COASTAL
CLEANUP DAY AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER IS SPONSORED BY THE
CALIFORNIA COASTAL COMMISSION
THIS IS ONE OF THE MOST WELL
KNOWN EFFORTS AND TO ADDRESS
PLASTIC POLLUTION IT WAS STARTED
IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE AND IT'S
THE LARGEST AS VOLUNTEER EVENT
IN THE STATE.
THE THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD HAS ADOPTED TRACK
WITH PEOPLE COMMON THE TRASH
AMENDMENTS AND WHICH PROHIBITS
STORM WATER SYSTEMS FROM
DISCHARGING TRASH LARGER THAN
FIVE MILLIMETERS SO BASICALLY
ANYTHING THAT'S NON.
MICROPROCESSOR INTO STATE WATERS --
INTO COMPLY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ARE NOW EITHER PURCHASING AND
INSTALLING FULL CAPTURE SYSTEM
TO CATCH THE TRASH IN THEIR
STORM DRAINS BEFORE IT GOES OUT
INTO THE OCEAN OR THEY'RE PAYING
FOR OTHER EQUIVALENT MEASURES.
THAT WOULD AND YOU COULD WIN TO
INSTALLING THESE KINDS OF FULL
CAPTURE SYSTEMS WE'VE BEEN
WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE WATER
BOARD ON THEIR EFFORTS IN THIS
REGARD.
ON THE CHEMISTRY SIDE OF THINGS
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TOXIC SUBSTANCES CONTROL RUNS
THE SAFER CONSUMER PRODUCTS
PROGRAM WHICH IDENTIFIES AND
EVALUATES AM.
CAN'T CHEMICALS OF CONCERN IN
CONSUMER PRODUCTS AND
STAKEHOLDERS THAT WORK ON
PLASTIC POLLUTION HAVE REYES
THIS CONCERN.
THAT CHEMICAL ADDITIVES IN
SINGLE USER LAKE FLORENTINO
COMPOUNDS AND PHTHALATES ARE NOW
ESCAPING INTO THE ENVIRONMENT
THROUGH THE PLASTIC WASTE.
I'M SO IN RESPONSE TO REQUESTS
FROM THE PUBLIC THE SAFER
CONSUMER PRODUCTS PROGRAM HAS
INCLUDED FAST FOOD PACKAGING.
IN THEIR TWENTY EIGHTEEN TWENTY
TWENTY PRIORITY PRODUCT WORK
PLAN.
I'M AND FINALLY OPC HAS BEEN
COORDINATING EXTENSIVELY WITH
POWER CYCLE AND SINCE TWENTY
TWELVE ON ITS PACKAGING POLICIES
AND MOST RECENTLY WE'VE BEEN
COORDINATING BOTH ON AND SB
THIRTEEN THIRTY FIVE AND
THINKING THROUGH HOW TO
IMPLEMENT --
THAT VERY IMPORTANT LEGISLATION
PROHIBITING FOODS.
A FOOD SERVICE FACILITIES IN
STATE BUILDINGS FROM USING AND
PACKAGING THAT'S NOT REUSABLE
RECYCLABLE OR COMPOSTABLE AND
WE'RE ALSO COORDINATING WITH
CHARISMATIC ON THEIR PILOT.
RE USE PROGRAM WHICH WOULD
PROVIDE GRANTS AND FOR PROJECTS
TO PROMOTE THE RE USE OF
PRODUCTS THAT WE AVOID THE
SINGLE USE AN AB CYCLE THAT
WE'VE GOTTEN OURSELVES INTO YOU.
SO IN CONCLUSION I AM I WOULD
JUST REMIND EVERYONE MARINE TO
READ TO LOSE OUR BEACHES THAT
CREATES A HAZARD FOR HUMANS IT
IN TANGLES AND IT POISONS
WILDLIFE.
IT EMPLOYS IS HUGE COSTS ON
LOCAL MUNICIPALITIES THROUGH
COLLECTION EFFORTS AND LOST
TOURISM REVENUE.
AND AND WE HAD A PC ARE
COMMITTED TO CONTINUE TO
COORDINATE EFFORTS TO REDUCE
MARINE DEBRIS AND WE WILL LEAD
COLLABORATIVE PARTNERSHIPS WILL
SUPPORT IMPLEMENTATION OF
RECOMMENDATIONS.
WE WILL FIND A TARGETED STUDIES
TO INFORM MANAGEMENT AND WE WILL
SHARE INFORMATION WITH DECISION
MAKERS INCLUDING ALL OF YOURSELF
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH.
OF THE ME BY THE BY THE WAY TO
GO JUST A QUICK MOMENT MOMENT OF
PERSONAL PRIVILEGE I SEE A
COUPLE YOUNG PEOPLE FROM MY
DISTRICT YOU'RE HERE WAS PART OF
THE HOUSE FOR IS CAPITAL CONVOY.
AND FANTASTIC YOUNG PEOPLE I
SPOKE TO THEM LAST NIGHT AND
EVERYTHING THEY WANT --
TO POLLUTION ISSUE SO IT'S THE
WORLD THAT WE'RE IN WE'RE GIVING
TO THEM THAT THAT THIS IS ALL
ABOUT TODAY SO --
GLAD TO GLAD TO SEE YOU GUYS
HERE.
I'M SORRY SECOND SPEAKER IS
DOCTOR CLEAR STEEL MINUTES IT IS
IS AN ASSISTANT.
PROFESSOR OF ENVIRONMENTAL
SCIENCE AND RESOURCE MANAGEMENT
AT CAL STATE CHANNEL ISLANDS AND
SHE'S AN APPLIED MARINE
ECOLOGIST A CONSERVATION
BIOLOGIST SHE'S GOT EXTENSIVE.
EXPERIENCE IN THIS AREA WITH
MORNING COASTAL ENVIRONMENTS IN
HER RESEARCH EXAMINES HUMAN
IMPACTS.
ON COASTAL SYSTEMS AND SHE
ASSESSES NATURAL RESOURCES.
I HAD TO HOW IT INFORMS COASTAL
MANAGEMENT AND HER CURRENT
RESEARCH I THINK FOCUSES ON THE
ECOLOGICAL IMPACTS OF OCEAN
LITTERING MICRO PLASTIC.
DEBRIS ON OUR COASTAL.
ECOSYSTEM SO SHE'S GOT A PHD
FROM UNIVERSITY OF RHODE ISLAND
AND NATURAL RESOURCES SCIENCE OR
MASTERS IS FROM TROPICAL COASTAL
MANAGEMENT.
FROM NEWCASTLE UNIVERSITY AND
HER BATCHES SCIENCES IN BIOLOGY
FROM UNIVERSITY OF YORK SO WE'VE
GOT TO GET BRITISH.
BACKGROUND AS WELL SO I LOVE
THAT AND WE WELCOME YOU DEBRA
I'M SORRY WE WE WELCOME YOU
CLEAR. FOR FOR THIS PRESENTATION
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
ALAN AND CHAIRMAN STERN INTO THE
SENATE IS FOR YOUR INTEREST SO I
ALONG WITH.
OTHERS IN THIS AT CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM ALONG AS
WITH RESEARCHERS AROUND THE
WORLD CITY --
THE IMPACT OF MICRO PLASTICS IN
THE MARINE ENVIRONMENT.
AND THIS IS AN AREA OF GROWING
AN INCREASE IN THE ACTIVE AREA
OF RESEARCH --
OVER ABOUT THE LAST FIFTEEN
YEARS SO WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT AND READ ANTI WHAT
MICROPLATE SIX IT'S GENERALLY
CONSIDERED. TO BE PLASTIC
PARTICLES AND FIBERS THAT ARE
LESS THAN FIVE MILLIMETERS DOWN
TO ABOUT ONE MICRON --
AND SO FOR REFERENCE --
ABOUT SEVENTY MY FRIENDS IS THE
WITH HUMAN HAIR SO THESE ARE
SMALL PARTICLES THAT MAY BE
MANUFACTURED TO BE SMALL AS IN
PRIMARY MARK PLASTICS LIKE
MICROBEADS --
OR THE THE RAW --
PALLETS OF PLASTIC LIKE MINERALS --
THERE'S ALSO SECONDARY MICHAEL
PLASTIC TO TO FORM FROM THE
FRAGMENTATION OF LARGER ITEMS --
THIS SEEMS TO HAPPEN PARTICULAR
ON BEACHES WHERE THERE'S HIGH UV
IRRADIATION A LOT OF ABRASION
THAT CAUSES LARGER ITEMS TO
BREAK DOWN --
IT ALSO OCCURS IS THAT ARE
DURING OF CLOTHING AND ALSO HAVE
IS FROM AERIAL THE POSITION OF
THINGS LIKE TIRE DUST.
AND YOU KNOW FLOATING FIBERS
FROM INDUSTRIAL CARPETING AND
SUCH DO YOU CAME UP WITH THE
TERM NURGLE --
AT THIS IN A LETTER AND THE THE
INTERNAL IS THE ROB.
THE MUPPET PALETTE YEAH.
OKAY.
SO --
THERE'S A WHOLE VARIETY OF OF
MATERIALS THAT ARE MANUFACTURE
EVERY YEAR A HUGE RANGE OF
PLASTICS WITH DIFFERENT
COMPOSITIONS THAT ARE
MANUFACTURED.
AND ALONG WITH THE PLASTICS
THEMSELVES THERE ARE A VARIETY
OF CHEMICALS ARE ASSOCIATED WITH
THEM INCLUDING ADDITIVES THAT
ARE USED --
TO PRODUCE PARTICULAR
CHARACTERISTICS IN PLASTIC LIKE
PLASTICIZERS PHTHALATES ANTI
STATIC AGENTS I'M SO THERE'S A
ARE.
CHEMICALS THAT ARE MANUFACTURED --
INTO THE PLASTIC BUT THEN IN THE
ENVIRONMENT.
CERTAIN CHEMICALS THINGS LIKE PC
BEES DDT'S CLUB BROMINATED FLAME
RETARDANTS TEND HAVE THIS
AFFINITY WHERE THEY WANNA STICK
ON TO THE SURFACE OF PLASTICS --
AND SO IT'S NOT ONLY THE
CONCERNED ABOUT PLASTICS IN A
MARMON IT'S ALSO ENVIRONMENTAL
CHEMICALS THAT MAY BE I'M
ASSOCIATED WITH THEM AND THESE
ARE CONSIDERED PRIORITY
CONTAMINANTS BY GAMMA
GOVERNMENTS.
BECAUSE THEIR PERSISTENT BY
ACCUMULATIVE AND OR TOXIC.
MICHAEL PLASTICS ARE LIKELY THE
MOST OF NUMERICALLY ABUNDANT
ITEMS OF PLASTIC IN THE OCEAN
TODAY AND THE QUANTITIES OF
MICHAEL PLASTICS ARE INEVITABLY
GOING TO INCREASE IN LARGE.
PART BECAUSE OF LARGER PLASTIC
RATING AND BREAKING UP INTO
MILLIONS OF MICRO PLASTIC PIECES.
AROUND THE GLOBE BUOYANT MICHAEL
PLASTICS ARE CONCENTRATED IN MID
OCEANIC GYRES SO CENTERS OF
CIRCULATION LIKE THE GREAT
PACIFIC GARBAGE PATCH I'M ALSO
AROUND CENTERS OF CIRCULATION --
RECENT STUDIES HAVE ESTIMATED.
THE NUMBER OF MY PLASTIC
PARTICLES FLOATING ON THE
SERVICE TO BE SOMETHING BETWEEN
FIFTEEN TO FIFTY ONE TRILLION
PARTICLES.
BUT WE SHOULD BE AWARE THAT NOT
ALL MANUFACTURED PLASTICS FLOAT --
AND THAT ALSO BIOFILMS
ACCUMULATE ON THE SURFACE OF
FLOODING PLASTICS THAT CAUSES
THEM TO SING DE INTO DEEP WATERS.
AND TO ACCUMULATE AND SENTIMENT.
THE PRESENCE OF MICHAEL PLASTICS
IN THE OCEAN IS NOW WELL
ESTABLISHED EVEN IN VERY REMOTE
ENVIRONMENTS FROM THE OCEAN AT
JOHNMYERS TO THE POLLS.
FROM THE COAST TO DEEP OCEAN
TRENCHES --
MY PROPOSES A MISS AMPLE FROM
BEACHES FROM SURFACE WATERS --
FROM DEEP WATERS INCLUDING IN
THE MARIANAS TRENCH THEY FOUND
SINGLE USE PLASTIC ITEMS.
ADEPTS GREATER THAN TEN THOUSAND
METERS.
AT IN THE TRENCHES MOST POLLUTED
REGIONS THEY FOUND A MAXIMUM OF
TWO THOUSAND PIECES OF MICHAEL
PLASTIC FOR LEADER OF SETTLEMENT.
AND THIRTEEN PIECES OUR LEADER
IN WATER SO IT'S CERTAIN OUT THE
OCEAN FROM THE SURFACE TO THE
DEBTS.
ANSWERING CALIFORNIANS TO SOME
OF THE WORK THAT WE'VE BEEN
DOING LOOKING AT MICHAEL PLASTIC
ON BEACHES AROUND CALIFORNIA WE
FOUND MY CLASSICS THAT EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF FIFTY ONE BEACH IS
THAT WE SAMPLED --
WE KNOW THAT.
RESIDENTS OF BEACHES LIKE TO
PACIFIC MALL CRABS ARE INGESTING
MICHAEL PLASTICS WITHIN ABOUT
35% MORE GRABS.
AND INGESTED MARKER FIVE SIX ON
THIS IS ONE MECHANISM THESE
FILTER FEEDING ORGANISMS THAT
ARE VERY COMMON ON BEACHES IN
CALIFORNIA. ONE MECHANISM OF
MICHAEL PLASTICS ENTERING INTO
COASTAL FOOD WEBS.
AND EVEN IN REMOTE PLACES LIKE
THE BEACHES OF OF THE CHANNEL
ISLANDS WE FIND --
MARINE DEBRIS AND ALSO MICHAEL
PLUS SIX ON THOSE BEACHES.
WE FIND MICHAEL PLASTICS BEING
DEPOSITED.
IN BIOLOGICAL COMMUNITIES SO WE
FOUND THAT --
PLASTIC WASTE CAN INCREASE THE
DISEASE RISK OF CORALS ANNA
ELEVATING DISEASE RISK ABOUT
TWENTY TIMES FOR FOR CROSS THAT
ARE ENVELOPED IN PLASTIC.
ABOUT 75% OF TURTLE GRASS AND
BELIEVES WAS FOUND TO HAVE OF
MICROPROCESSOR ON THE SURFACE
AND THE CENTER CITY THEM
MENTIONS THAT MICHAEL PLASTICS
ASSOCIATE WITH --
PHYTOPLANKTON AGGREGATE SO THIS
IS ONE MECHANISM OF MICHAEL
PLASTIC SINKING INTO SETTLEMENTS
IN DEEPER WATERS.
IS THAT --
WHAT MIGHT BE A BUOYANT PLASTIC
AND BECOMES A NEGATIVE THE GOING
AND WITH CHEN GENERALLY SINK
DOWN INTO THE SETTLEMENTS?
MIKE ABOUT SIX SEVEN FOUND ON
THE BODIES OF A HUGE VARIETY OF
MARINE ORGANISMS INCLUDING AND
INVERTEBRATES AND FISH AND BIRDS
AND MAMMALS.
OVER TWO HUNDRED TWENTY SPECIES
HAVE BEEN FOUND TO CAN SEEM LIKE
A PLASTIC AND MORE THAN HALF OF
THOSE ARE COMMERCIALLY TARGETED
SPECIES.
THE SMALL SIZE AMERICA PLASTICS
IS PROBLEMATIC BECAUSE MANY
ORGANISMS ACROSS A HUGE RANGE OF
SIZES CAM CONSUME THEM AND THEY
MAY NOT BE ABLE TO DISTINGUISH
MIKE PLASTICS FROM THEIR NATURAL
PLAYED PREY ITEMS.
SO WE SEE DIRECT CONSUMPTION OF
MICHAEL PLASTICS BY FILTER
FEEDING ORGANISMS LIKE SOME OF
THE ONES SEEN HERE FROM ALL THE
WAY FROM PLANKTON UP TO
MEGAFAUNA LIKE MANTA RAYS.
AND WE'VE SEEN A MICRO PLASTICS
THAT ARE DIRECTLY CONSUMED BY TO
TRY TO FORCE LIKE THE MARANISS
TRANCHE AMPHIPODS SO FOUND IN
THE REALLY DEEP OCEANS --
WITH THE SENTIMENT FINDING --
THEM HAVE THEY'VE CONSUMED
MICHAEL PLASTICS --
EVEN ENDANGERED SPECIES IN
CALIFORNIA LIKE THE TIDE WATER
GOBIES.
WE RECENTLY FOUND MICHAEL
PLASTICS IN THEIR GILLS.
AND SPECIES OF SEA BIRD THAT IN
JUST OCEAN OF ALSO BEEN SHOWN.
TO TO INGEST MICROPROCESSOR.
SO THEN THE CONCERNS ABOUT MICRO
PLASTIC ARE THAT WE KNOW THAT
ORGANISMS ARE EATING THEM ONE OF
THE POTENTIAL CONSEQUENCES SO WE
SEE PHYSICAL CONSEQUENCES SO
CLOGGING OF THE GOD OR SATIATION
SO THE ANIMALS ARE NOT.
MOTIVATED TO FEED --
THAT LEAST ALTERED FEEDING
BEHAVIOUR POTENTIALLY IMPACTION
OF GOT PERFORATION AND TISSUE
DAMAGE SO THESE ARE ALL PHYSICAL
EFFECTS.
AND THEN THERE MAY BE CHEMICAL
EFFECTS FROM MICHAEL PLASTICS
THAT INCLUDE A TOXICITY WHICH
MAY BE DUE TO THE PLASTICS OR
CHEMICALS THAT ARE ASSOCIATED
WITH THEM --
INFLAMMATORY RESPONSES IMMUNE
RESPONSES AND IMPACTS TO
REPRODUCTION AND GROWTH SO
GENERALLY A LOT OF THE LIBERTY
STUDIES --
AND FEEL CITIES THAT HAVE SHOWN
IMPACTS OF MICHAEL PLASTIC TEND
TO BE -- THE
SUBTLE EFFECTS THAT ARE SUB
LETHAL SO IMPACTS ON
REPRODUCTION IMPACTS ON GROWTH --
OR IMPACTS OF INDIVIDUAL
MORTALITY WE'RE NOT WE HAVEN'T
DEMONSTRATED REALLY VERY BROAD
POPULATION AND COMMUNITY LEVEL
EFFECTS OF MICRO PLASTIC RIGHT
NOW.
BUT IT'S CERTAINLY SOMETHING WE
SHOULD BE CONCERNED ABOUT
BECAUSE MIKE PLASTICS ARE
OBVIOUSLY INCREASING --
AND OUR ABILITY TO DETECT THEM
AND TO DETECT THEIR EFFECT IS
GOING TO CONTINUE TO INCREASE IN
THE FUTURE.
SO THESE ON GROWING CONCERNS AS
I MENTIONED THAT MY REPLY SIX
ARE UBIQUITOUS IN MARINA
VARMINTS THEY ARE INCREASING --
OVER TIME.
AND THERE SEEMS TO BE EVIDENCE
OF A FACT --
VERTICALLY ON VULNERABLE LIFE
HISTORY STAGES REPRODUCTIVE
EFFECTS --
THAT COULD HAVE POPULATION LEVEL
CONSEQUENCES.
THE SEAFOOD CONSUMPTION IS ONE
PATHWAY --
FOR PLASTICS EXPOSURE WE KNOW
THAT THEIR PRESENT IN OUR
COMMERCIALLY IMPORTANT SPECIES --
COMMERCIALLY IMPORTANT SPECIES
LIKE MUSCLES AND OYSTERS AND
FISH IS THAT ARE SOLD FOR HUMAN
CONSUMPTION.
BUT IN MY REC REPRESENT A
RELATIVELY SMALL BURDEN TO THE
INDIVIDUAL CONSUMERS SO
SOMETHING LIKE FIFTY TWO HUNDRED
PARTICLES PER MUSCLE --
AND IT A VERY COMMITTED SEAFOOD
EATER MIGHT CONSUME AS MANY AS
ELEVEN THOUSAND PARTICLES PER
YEAR.
SO THESE BY ACCUMULATION AND
FOOD CHAIN AFFECTED NOT YET WELL
UNDERSTOOD BUT WE SHOULD HAVE
CONCERN ABOUT THIS ISSUE BECAUSE
MY CAPACITY CONTAMINATION OF THE
AQUATIC ENVIRONMENTS WILL
CONTINUE TO INCREASE IN THE
FORESEEABLE FUTURE.
AND THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT
KNOWLEDGE GAPS CURRENTLY --
ABOUT THE THE EFFECTS OF MICRO
PLASTICS ON OUR MARINE
ENVIRONMENT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
SOBERING SOBERING PRESENTATIONS
BOTH AND WE APPRECIATE YOU BEING
HERE SO LET'S OPEN UP THE THE
FLORIDA QUESTIONS FOLKS HAVE
THINGS THEY WANT TO ASK ABOUT.
AS THEIR MONEY.
THANK YOU I WANT TO THANK YOU
BOTH I THINK.
DR STEALS PRESENTATION YOU
ALLUDED TO IT [inaudible]
BUT THE FOOD CHAIN [inaudible]
STUDIES ON FISH PRODUCTS
CONSUMED BY HUMANS.
ARE WE IS THERE DATA OR EVIDENCE
SHOWING THE PLASTICS BEING
TRANSFERRED.
INTO HUMANS.
THERE ARE STUDIES THAT HAVE
SHOWN THAT HUMANS ARE CONSUMING
MICHAEL PLASTICS AND AND THERE
ARE STUDIES THAT SHOW.
THE ABILITY OF MICHAEL PLASTICS
TO TRANSFER FROM A PRIMER
CONSUMING TO A SECONDARY
CONSUMERS SO IT CERTAINLY DOES
SEEM TO BE --
A RISK ALTHOUGH THE AS A SAY THE
THE ACTUAL.
LOAD OF MICHAEL PLASTICS IS A
RELATIVELY SMALL CONTRIBUTION OF
THE DIET.
AND THEN THIS PAST YEAR THE
OCEAN PROTECTION COUNCIL FUNDED
A STUDY WE DON'T HAVE THE
RESULTS YET I'M TO LOOK AT
WHETHER MICRO PLASTICS ARE
SERVING AS A VECTOR FOR DISEASE --
SO AS WE CAN SEEM SEAFOOD --
IS THERE SOME SORT OF THAT
TRANSFER OF DISEASE TO HUMANS.
TO THE PUBLIC HEALTH CONSEQUENCE
I THINK IS THE WAY TO EXPAND.
ON CULTURE STERN ALLUDED TO SOME
PEOPLE THINK WELL THIS IS JUST
TO COASTAL PROBLEM OR AN OCEAN
IS A PROBLEM.
BUT THOSE VECTORS OF HUMAN
HEALTH IMPACTED.
THAT SEEN ANYBODY LIVING
ANYWHERE POTENTIALLY IMPACTED IN.
IS ARE THERE ON IS THE OPC
SUPPORTING ONGOING PUBLIC HEALTH
STUDIES ON THIS ASPECT OF
PLASTIC POLLUTION.
YES [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CAN YOU TELL ME IF THE IF THERE
ANY.
POSITIVE STORIES FROM AROUND THE
WORLD THAT YOU HAVE COME ACROSS
THAT GIVE YOU A LITTLE BIT OF
HOPE POLICY SOLUTIONS OR OR
BEHAVIORAL CHANGES THAT YOU SEEN
AN ANYWHERE --
THAT THAT WE CAN DRAW SOME
LESSONS FROM.
THAT WHERE WERE BEACH IS OR OR
MARINE ECO SYSTEMS HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO BOUNCE BACK.
AS SO THERE'S A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS IN THERE I THINK THERE
ARE SOME HOPEFUL STORIES I DON'T
KNOW WHERE MARINE ECOSYSTEMS
HAVE FOUND BACK.
AND BUT I THINK IT RIGHT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE SOME REALLY.
INSPIRATIONAL STORIES IN TERMS
OF THE THE PLASTIC BAG MAN IS A
GREAT EXAMPLE A STARTED AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL YOU KNOW GOVERNMENTS
HERE AND THERE.
AND CITIES STARTED BANNING
PLASTIC BAGS AND THEN IT.
IT BLOSSOMED INTO THIS AND OTHER
REGIONS I THINK I'M CHAIRMAN
STERN MENTIONED --
THE OR MAYBE IT WAS CHAIRMAN ON
I'M SORRY.
WHAT?
IS HE HE MENTIONED THE WORK
THAT'S GOING ON INTERNATIONALLY
AND IN THE U. K. IT'S IT TO
REALLY TAKE ON THIS NOTION OF
THE CIRCULAR ECONOMY.
I THINK THERE'S SOME REAL --
STRIDES THAT ARE BEING MADE IN
DEVELOPING NEW PRODUCTS THAT ARE --
YOU KNOW.
MADE OUT OF DIFFERENT DIFFERENT
ELEMENTS THEN PETROLEUM PRODUCTS
IN THAT BREAKDOWN IN DIFFERENT
WAYS AND ARE MORE
ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY AND
THAT WE SHOULD BE LOOKING AT AND
AND CONSIDERING --
IN OUR IN OUR SYSTEMS AS WELL.
I CAN I JUST MENTIONED SO
THERE'S THIS OF TWO AREAS OF
CONCERN WITH MICHAEL PLASTICS
ONE AS MICROFIBER IS WHICH SEEM
TO BE THE THE DOMINANT.
ABOUT MICHAEL MICHAEL PLASTIC
PARTICLE --
SO AT DRESSING --
THAT FROM A WASTE WATER
PERSPECTIVE MIGHT BE REALLY --
ONE WAY TO MAKE GREAT STRIDES
WITH THAT AND THEN THE OTHER --
LITTLE BIT OF HOPE THAT I WOULD
LIKE TO THROW OUT THERE IS --
THE FRAGMENT THE PREDOMINANT ON
BEACHES AND THAT IS ONE AREA
THAT PEOPLE ARE MAKING BIG
DIFFERENCES IN AN ACTUAL
CLEANING UP AND SERVE.
THAT BEING A MAJOR SOURCE OF
FRAGMENTS OF MY CAPACITY --
IS ONE WAY THAT WE CAN --
HOPEFULLY REDUCE THEM ENTERING
INTO THE OCEAN SO IT'S A BEACH
CLEAN UP ALTHOUGH THEY SEEM LIKE
ARE YOU KNOW THEY ARE IMPORTANT
SORT OF SOCIAL OUT REACHED
PEOPLE --
THEY CAN ACTUALLY REALLY
IMPACTFUL IN REDUCING THE AMOUNT
OF MY CLASSES THAT BEING
GENERATED --
SURE YEAH.
SIR THERE VITAL YOU'RE CERTAIN.
WE DROVE DOWN A LITTLE MORE ON
JUST THE THE STATE OF RESEARCH
YOU TALKED ABOUT KNOWLEDGE GAPS
AND WHERE IS THIS SORT OF
SCIENCE AND RESEARCH COMMUNITY
HEADING WITH THIS AND WHAT DO
YOU GUYS SEE GOING FORWARD SAY
IN THE NEXT.
YEAR TO THAT.
CENTER MY MISSION THE PUBLIC
HEALTH SIDE OF THINGS --
THAT'S A I THINK OF SMART --
PAST THE TO TO GO DOWN CERTAINLY
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT UP TAKE LOOKS
LIKE IF I MEAN.
AM I RIGHT TO SAY THAT DOCTOR
STEAL IT SOME OF THE GAPS AROUND
THE LIKE THE INTERACTION BETWEEN
THE INGESTED PLASTIC ITSELF AND
WHAT GOES INTO THE THE TISSUE SO
IN OTHER WORDS.
THE QUANTIFYING ME YOU USED
ELEVEN THOUSAND PARTICLES PER
PERSON -- AS
A THAT AMOUNT IS DETECTED IN IN
SPECIFIC AND THAT'S THAT'S
ESTIMATED FOR A EUROPEAN
CONSIDERED LIKE A HIGH LEVEL
EUROPEAN CONSUMER OF OF SEAFOOD
YEAH OKAY SO HOW HI SEAFOOD
CONSUMER IN EUROPE IS A IS THAT
ELEVEN THOUSAND WORLD.
AND BUT BUT THE INTERACTION
BETWEEN.
THE THE THE THE MARINE LIFE
INGESTION AND THEN THAT PASSED
THROUGH THAT STILL NOT ENTIRELY
UNDERSTOOD LIKE WE KNOW THAT IT
ENDS UP IN THE PERSON WE DON'T
KNOW EXACTLY.
HOW IT GETS THERE AN INTERESTING
HUMANS IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO
DETECT --
YOU KNOW THE IMPACT FOR MY
PURPOSES FROM OTHER SOURCES FOR
EXAMPLE SO THE BARTER STUDIES A
LOOKING AT DID YOU TRANSFER OR A
FOUNDRY COULD YOU TRANSFER.
OF ORGANIC POLLUTANTS FROM
MICHAEL SAM'S SO WE KNOW THAT
THAT OCCURS --
BUT IT'S I DON'T KNOW OF ANY
HUMAN STUDIES THAT WOULD BE
GOING ON IT WAS VERY DIFFICULT
TO SEPARATE THAT OUT FROM --
JUST SORT OF GENERAL EXPOSURE
BUT YOU HAVE TO SORT YOU WORK
BACKWARDS FROM DO YOU DO YOU EAT
ANYTHING OUT OF THE OCEAN OR NOT.
YET UNDERSTOOD YES SO I I'M
FEELING A LITTLE WORSE ABOUT --
SUSHI.
SO SO CAN I JUST MENTION TO MAKE
PEOPLE FEEL A LITTLE BIT BETTER
ABOUT THINGS SO THE THE WHOLE
ORGANISM CONSUMES LIKE A MUSCLE
FOR EXAMPLE.
THE MICROPHONE SIX TEND TO BE IN
THE GUT OF THE ANIMAL SO WE CAN
SEE A WHOLE MUSCLE READING.
EVERYTHING ABOUT THE ANIMAL BUT
FOR FISHES FOR EXAMPLE --
THEIR FILLETED MOST MIKE
PLASTICS WOULD NOT BE IN THE IN
THE MUSCLE TISSUE SO BUT FOR THE
EUROPEAN CONSUMER YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT THEY CAN'T IMAGINE THEY'RE
JUST EATING FISH BELLIES THIS
THIS WOULD BE SEVENTY THOSE
WOULD BE EATING A LOT OF
SHELLFISH. FOR EXAMPLE AN OFFICE
SAYS SHELLFISH IS THE PRIMARY
OKAY OR OR OR OTHER FISHES THAT
ARE CONSUMED HOLE.
IS THE REASON IT'S NOT KOSHER
YES EXACTLY.
AND IS IT IT'S LIKE A LITTLE
GUILT TRIP TO DO I DO HAVE --
CHAIR OF THE JEWISH CAUCUSES
WELL -- ADAM
POSE LITTLE BUT SO IN ADDITION
TO PUBLIC HEALTH THE THIS SORT
OF BROADER IMPACT ISSUE WITHIN
SORT OF MARINE HEALTH AS AN
ECOSYSTEM ITSELF NOT SO MUCH IN
THE FISH CONSUMPTION SIDE OF
THINGS.
CAN YOU ARTICULATE A LITTLE MORE
ABOUT -- THE
STATE OF SO I I'D LIKE TO STRESS
THAT THIS IS AN ADDITIVE PROBLEM
SO I ALONG WITH ALL THE OTHER
ISSUES IN THE MARINE ENVIRONMENT
WITH OVER HARVESTING AND
POLLUTION.
AND CLIMATE CHANGE THAT THIS IS
AN ADDITIONAL STRESSOR THAT
ORGANISMS ARE UNDERGOING SO IT'S
LIKELY GIVEN THAT WE'VE
DEMONSTRATED EFFECTS ON
REPRODUCTION FOR EXAMPLE OR AN
INFLAMMATORY RESPONSES THAT
THERE COULD BE --
POPULATION LEVEL AND AND
COMMUNITY LEVEL AFFECTS SO
ECOSYSTEMS BEING DAMAGED BY THIS
YOUR MICROCLIMATE STICKS.
A CERTAINLY AS AS MICHAEL PLUS
THE INCREASE WE MIGHT EXPECT TO
SEE MORE PREVALENT.
IMPACTS TO MARINE COMMUNITIES
LIKE THAT.
THAT.
COULD MEAN COULD THIS SOUP AND
UP AT OUR SHORES I GUESS LET ME
PUT IT MORE POINTEDLY THAT THAT
MICRO PLASTIC.
WHAT WOULD LIVES IN THOSE ON
THOSE ISLANDS YOU KNOW THAT WE
WE TALK WE'RE NOT JUST BIG
PIECES RIGHT BUT THERE?
IT IT CREATES.
A SORT OF VISCOUS QUALITY IN THE
WATER YES.
MAY I WITH A WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
IT AS THAT.
AS OUR LUCIEN CLOUD EXPANDS THAT
WE MAY ACTUALLY SEE MORE
INTERFACE WITH THIS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES I MEAN WE'RE SEE
MORE ON THE CALIFORNIA COAST NOT
LESS IN THE FUTURE.
WELL IT'S IT'S CERTAINLY GLOBAL
PROBLEM WE KNOW THAT FIVE SIX OR
SIX CIRCULATING IN THE OCEANS
AND SO.
I THINK IT WILL DEPEND A LOT ON
OUR ACTIONS IN REDUCING LOCAL
SOURCES OF WE WE HAVE CONTROL
OVER THOSE ACTIONS YOU SAW THE
RED AROUND R. COSTA YOU SHOW
THAT GLOBAL MAP OF ALL THE HOT
SPOT.
I GET A BIG --
A DARK RED OFF THE WEST COAST
THE UNITED STATES I READ THAT
MAP RIGHT IS THAT CORRECT YEAH
SO THAT'S YOU KNOW CONSEQUENCE
OF THERE BEING A LOT OF PEOPLE
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA OR THE
WEST COAST.
AND THE MICHAEL PLASTIC THAT
WE'RE SEEING ARE EIGHT YOU KNOW
IN TERMS OF SYNTHETIC FIBERS AND
SUCH OFF OUR SHORES SO --
IT'S A RELATIVELY LOW SLIGHTLY
LOWER DENSITY IN THE WATER
SLIGHTLY HIGHER DENSITY IN THE
SENTIMENTS BUT IT CERTAINLY
PRESENT ALONG WITH CALIFORNIA'S.
BUT IT'S NOT FAIR TO BLAME CHINA.
IT'S DIFFICULT TO SAY THE
SOURCES OF MICRO PLASTIC
POLLUTION THIS IS ONE OF THE
MAJOR ISSUES THAT WE HAVE
BECAUSE THEY ARE.
SMALL PARTICLES THAT DON'T COME
STAMPED WITH THE MADE IN CHINA
KIND OF YOU KNOW STAMP SO IT'S
DIFFICULT TO SAY.
THE SOURCES OF POLLUTION WE KNOW
THAT THEY CIRCULATE SO WE GO OFF
THE COAST TWENTY MILES TO THE
CHANNEL ISLANDS.
I'LL BE FINE MICHAEL PLASTICS
THERE SO WE KNOW THEY'RE
CIRCULATING FROM THE COAST AND
AND OUT.
INTO THE OCEAN WATERS SO IT'S
DIFFICULT TO PIN DOWN THE
SOURCES OF MY PROPOSED SOLUTION --
A LOT OF WHAT WE CAN DO IS
REALLY JUST IDENTIFYING THE
TYPES OF PLASTIC IN LOOKING AT
THE LIKELY SOURCES SO WHEN WE
FIND SYNTHETIC FIBERS WE THINK
THEY PROBABLY COME FROM WASTE
WATER FROM DOMESTIC WASHING
MACHINES FOR EXAMPLE --
BUT IT'S HARD TO SAY EXACTLY
WHERE MICHAEL PLASTICS --
WHERE ANY ONE INDIVIDUAL MIKE
BLESSING TO COME FROM?
AND THAT'S ACTUALLY PART OF THE
MICROPROCESSOR CHATTED G. THAT
AND THAT WE'RE DEVELOPING RIGHT
NOW IS HELPING TO FIGURE OUT IS
STANDARDIZED METHODOLOGY FOR
CHARACTERIZING.
THE DIFFERENT TYPES OF
MICROPROCESSOR THAT THEN WE CAN
BEGIN TO TAKE STEPS TO ADDRESS
AND THE SOURCES.
WELCOME SENATOR JACKSON.
YES YOU SEE I IS A BRING THEIR
EXPERTISE TO BEAR DOCTOR STEEL
JUST PERFECT ROUNDUP WELCOME.
YEAH.
THEN WE GOT.
OUR BACKGROUNDER ON PAGE THREE
TALKS ABOUT GLOBAL RESPONSES CAN
EACH OF YOU A COMMENT ON THE
EUROPEAN UNION DIRECTIVE THAT
WAS PASSED LAST WINTER.
BANNING OR REACHING A FAN OF
MANY SINGLE USE PLASTIC ITEMS.
SETTING MINIMUM CONTENTS AND
FORTUNATELY THIS LEGISLATURE WAS
UNABLE TO GET TO A MINIMUM
CONTENT ON PLASTIC IN IN A CALL
FOR EXTEND PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITIES --
WHICH THIS.
LEGISLATURE WAS ON THE ROAD TO
GET TO IT AT ON THE WHAT THE
EUROPEANS JUST DID. FOUR MONTHS
AGO.
I WELL I CAN CERTAINLY TALK TO
WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT WHAT'S IN THE
MARINE ENVIRONMENTS ABOUT 8290%
OF THE PLASTIC THAT WE'RE SEEING
IN THE ENVIRONMENT COME FROM
SINGLE HE'S PLASTIC SO IT SEEMS
LIKE -- A
GOOD WAY OF REDUCING THE AMOUNT
OF OCEAN PLASTICS TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUE OF SINGLE USE PLASTIC.
YEAH I THINK THEY THEY WHEN THEY
AUTHORED AT THEY TALK ABOUT THE
MARINE DEBRIS ISN'T AS AS THE
GOAL.
MR MISUNDERSTAND YEAH I IS SO I
THINK THAT THIS IS AN AREA WHERE
WE ACTUALLY DO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN FROM OUR
COLLEAGUES AROUND THE WORLD AND
AND TO TAKE.
THEM VERY LEADERSHIP.
IN IN HAND SO AND THE E. U. HAS
BEEN QUITE AGGRESSIVE ON
PLASTICS AND I THINK AND YOU
KNOW.
IN AT I THINK IT WAS IN.
WRITTEN IN THE BRITAIN IS THE
FIRST PLACE WHERE STARBUCKS
ANNOUNCED IT WAS GOING TO
ELIMINATE STRIDES LAST YEAR AND
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK ON
EXTENDED PRODUCER RESPONSIBILITY
AND ON AND SOURCE REDUCTION AND
ON EXTENDED PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY.
AND AND I THINK WE NEED TO WE
NEED TO BE LEARNING FROM THIS
COUNTRY'S.
CAN I FOLLOW UP YOU HAD YOUR
THREE PRONGED YEAH --
AGENCY OR YOU'RE THE COUNCIL IS
WORKING ON YOUR SOURCE
PRODUCTION.
THE CITY OF ALAMEDA NICE CITY
HIGHLAND FORTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
YOU SPEND FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS I BELIEVE AND YOU GET.
TEN TEN RESTAURANTS A REDUCE
THEIR PLASTICS AND SAVE FORTY
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS EACH PER
YEAR IS THAT I GET THAT RIGHT ON
THE SEA WE SPENT IT WAS FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLAR PILOT
PROJECT THE GOAL IS ULTIMATELY
TO GET HUNDRED RESTAURANTS.
AND PARTICIPATING TODAY WE HAVE
FORTY SIX PARTICIPATING AND SO
WE ARE WE'RE ABOUT HALFWAY AND
IT THE DATA THAT I HAD WAS ONLY
FROM TEN OF THOSE FORTY SIX SO
IT'S AS A SMALL PERCENTAGE BUT I
GUESS.
THANK YOU. ONE OTHER THING YOU
KNOW WE'RE GONNA DO OUR BEST TO
TRY TO REDUCE --
WASTIN AND AND WERE ACTUALLY
HEARING A BILL LATER ON TODAY
YOU ABOUT THIS VERY TOPIC --
BUT BUT HOW HOW MUCH OF RIVER OF
NO RETURN WITH REGARDS TO THIS
IMPACT ON HOW WE GONNA CLEAN UP.
YOU KNOW THIS THIS POLLUTION
THAT EXIST IN SO MANY PLACES IN
OUR OCEANS --
WHAT WHAT IS THE?
WITH THE GLOBAL PLAN ON ON ON ON
DEALING WITH THE PROBLEM AS
ALREADY EXISTS AS OPPOSED.
TO TRY TO REDUCE.
THE IMPACT OF THE PROBLEM IN THE
FUTURE.
I THINK THIS IS A LOT LIKE
CLIMATE CHANGE AND I THOUGHT I
WOULD SAY THAT IT IS A GLOBAL
PROBLEM WE ARE CONTINUING TO
EMITS PLASTIC PARTICLES JUST AS
WORRIED MEETING.
AIRBORNE CARBON DIOXIDE
PARTICLES AND AND IT'S GOING TO
REQUIRE LOCAL ACTION AND GLOBAL
ACTION AND AT SOME POINT WE'RE
NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO CLEAN UP
WHATEVER IS OUT THERE.
AND AND GET RID OF IT BUT WE DO
HAVE TO STOP OUR OUR CONTINUED
PRODUCTION IS THERE ANY
EFFECTIVE WAY OF MITIGATING THE
THE MICRO CLASSICS PROBLEM AS IT
EXISTS RIGHT NOW [inaudible]
NOW.
I DON'T BELIEVE THERE'S A WAY TO
MITIGATE MY PROPOSES ONCE
THEY'RE IN THE ENVIRONMENT AND
THE REALLY ALL WE NEED TO YOU
KNOW THAT THE MAJOR THING THAT
WE NEED TO DO IS TO REDUCE THE
SOURCE OF THEM THERE'S THERE'S
THERE THERE'S NO EFFECTIVE WAY
CURRENTLY.
TO TAKE THEM OUT OF THE
ENVIRONMENT.
NEVER GONE AWAY WHAT IF I MAY
THAT THE TRASH WE'LL.
RIGHT I MEAN THE THE HIPPOS OUT
THERE THEY CANNOT GRAB THIS
STUFF UP RIGHT THAT'S WHY IT'S
AND MIKE RUNNER THE TRASH WAS
PICKED UP THE BIG STUFF RIGHT
RIGHT YEAH.
YES IN THE CHAT THE IDEA THE
TRASH WILL IS TO PREVENT THAT
TRASH FROM BECOMING MORE MICRO
PLAZA.
SENATOR HAS AN IDEA WE CAN GET
HASBRO -- TO
TO SUBMIT TO BASICALLY SPONSOR
HUNGRY HIPPOS.
GO OUT THERE AND AND HARBORS ALL
UP AND DOWN THE COAST YOU LAUGH
YEAH NO IT'S A GOOD IDEA.
YEAH WELL THERE ARE PROJECTS
LIKE AND YOU KNOW LEGOS IS
STARTING TO USE RECYCLED PLASTIC
GET'S LEGACY IT IS THIS IS ONE
AREA WHERE.
AND YEAH AT THE THERE'S NOT.
THANK YOU. TO BOTH CHAIRMAN'S IN
THAT THANK YOU FOR THE VERY --
EDUCATIONAL --
SO GUY IN AND WE'VE HEARD ABOUT --
MICHAEL PLASTICS AND IN THE
OCEANS AND IT'S NICE TO HEAR --
EDUCATED PEOPLE TALK ABOUT IT.
AND HOW WE CAN --
MEDICAID IN SOME WAYS SO I I'M
JUST A FEW QUESTIONS --
IN ANY KIND OF ALLUDED TO BEFORE
READY NOT KNOWING BUT DO WE KNOW
WHAT THE U. S. CONTRIBUTION IS
TO THE OVERALL PROBLEM IN THE
OCEAN STARTING WITH LARGE
PLASTICS BEING.
ADDED I MEAN I THINK.
A LOT OF CLOSE TO COMMUNITIES --
EMILY COMMUNITIES THAT MATTER
HAVE GOOD SORTING MECHANISMS TO
GET THE PLASTICS --
EITHER RECYCLED OR UNFORTUNATELY
ONLY 11% I THINK A RECYCLE THE
REST OF IT ARE PUT INTO
LANDFILLS AND AND ELSEWHERE AND
I THINK.
OF THE EASTERN SEABOARD IS
PROBABLY EQUALLY AS A CONSCIOUS
AS WE ARE --
BUT WHAT WHAT LITTLE I HAVE SEEN
IN AND AND AND THE WAY A
DOCUMENTARY USES A SHOWING THAT
ASIA IS A VERY STRONG --
THE MATTER IF YOU WILL OF THE
GROSS PLASTICS INTO OUR OCEANS
AT THE TERRY AND BECOME A
MICROFIBER SELECTION OF THAT
NUMBER ONE NUMBER --
TWO THE TOXICOLOGY OF MICRO
FIBERS TO HUMANS THE THE THE
CONCERN THE MICRO FIBERS AYE
AYES I ASSUME FROM MY MY
BACKGROUND AT THE MICRO FIBERS
ARE NON DIGESTIBLE --
I SOONER JUST EXCRETED BUT MAYBE
THERE IS SOME --
DANGERS TO HUMANS AND I'D LIKE
TO KNOW ABOUT ANY TOXICOLOGY
STUDIES THAT HAVE BEEN --
DISCUSSED.
AND THE NEW BROUGHT UP THAT THE
LA AREA WHERE WE PROBABLY DON'T
REALLY THINK ABOUT VERY MUCH AND
AND THAT IS --
WASHING THE WASHING MACHINE --
EFFLUENT YOU KNOW THAT A LOT OF
OUR PERMITS TODAY SOME HAVE
FORMS OF PLASTIC AND AND SOME OF
THESE PLASTIC COFFEE MICRO
FIBERS ARE MAKING THEIR WAY INTO
OUR WATER SUPPLY IN THAT WAY
THEY'RE GETTING OUT INTO THE
OCEAN SO.
AND I THINK THAT THE PUBLIC IS
REALLY NOT REALLY --
AWARE OF THAT AND SO.
WE HAVE WASHING MACHINES AT YOU
KNOW PROTECT THE ENGINE OF THE
WASHING MACHINES AND DRYERS SO
WHAT WITH --
FILTERS AND WASHING FACTORS TO
RECOGNIZE THIS PROBLEM AND YOU
KNOW YOU CAN PUT A MICRON FILTER
IN THERE TO YOU KNOW JUST LIKE
WE CAN.
TAKE A LENT OUT OF THE DRYERS TO
TO MEDICAID THIS THIS PROBLEM
THAT --
MAYBE JUST HASN'T BEEN
ILLUMINATED ENOUGH FOR THE
THOUGHT FOR THE PUBLIC AND
CERTAINLY THE MANY FACTORS OF
THE MACHINES UNDERSTAND.
YES THANK YOU S. SENATOR AND THE
FIRST OF US AS FAR AS THE UNITED
STATES CONTRIBUTION I DON'T HAVE
THOSE EXACT NUMBERS NOW I CAN
CERTAINLY AND LOOK FOR THOSE.
I I WOULD NOTE THAT AND THEY'VE
PROBABLY CHANGED SIGNIFICANTLY
SINCE CHINA STOPPED ACCEPTING A
MOST OF OUR RECYCLABLES AN
ANSWER NOW OUR WASTE STREAM
DIVERSION IS IS VERY DIFFERENT
THAN IT WAS JUST A COUPLE OF
YEARS AGO AND OUR IMPACT ON THE
ENVIRONMENT.
AND ARE GOING TO BE DIFFERENT
AND YOU KNOW THAT THE IMPACTS
FROM CHINA MAY BE DIFFERENT AS
WELL SO -- I
CAN LOOK INTO THAT FOR YOU AND
IN TERMS OF THE I I AM GOING TO
DEFER TO DOCTOR STEEL ON THE
DANGERS OF PLASTICS HUMANS AND
AND HOW THEY INTERACT.
WITH THE HUMAN BODY THAT IS ONE
OF THE STUDIES THAT WERE WERE
FINDING RIGHT NOW BUT I DON'T
KNOW THE RESULTS.
AND AND AS FAR AS AS WASHING
THAT THAT IS DEFINITELY THE AND
A POPULAR IDEA RIGHT NOW AND
SOMETHING WE'VE BEEN CONTACTED
AT IF YOU SEE ABOUT.
AND AS WE DO OUR AS WE ROLL OUT
OR PROP SIXTY EIGHT FUNDING
PROPOSALS AND COMPETITIVE GRANT --
ARE IF HE'S THERE WILL PROBABLY
INCLUDE THINGS ALONG THOSE LINES
TO SEE WHAT KINDS OF
TECHNOLOGIES ARE OUT THERE TO
REALLY FACILITATE AND THAT
MEDICATION ASPECT.
YEAH I'M I'M JUST AS CONCERNED
AS YOU ARE WITH --
CHINA LONGER EXPECTED --
ACCEPTING OUR PLASTICS --
SO.
THERE WAS EVER A TIME TO YOU
KNOW REALLY ADDRESS THE THE
ECYCLING EFFORTS UNDER WAY IN
AND WE HAVE SOME BILLS THAT
WE'RE GONNA BE ENTERTAINING THIS
YEAR DUE. TO INCREASE EVER SAY
11% IS JUST DEPLORABLE LOW WE WE
WILL AND WE HAVE TO COME UP WITH
A BETTER SYSTEM --
TO CERTAINLY --
TAKE THE THE PLASTICS OF OUR
LANDFILLS AND MAKE SURE THAT THE
CLASSIC STONED AND UP INTO.
INTO OUR OCEANS AND SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE TO ENSURE THAT WE WE
EFFECTUATE SOME SOME LEADERSHIP
IN THE SAME.
WE GOT A A BIGELOW BE A LOT OF
WATER WE HAVE A LOT OF COUNTRIES
THAT DON'T HAVE THE
ENVIRONMENTAL STEWARDSHIP THAT
THAT.
WE WOULD LIKE TO HAVE HERE IN
THE UNITED STATES AND WE NEED TO
DO WE CAN TO AS AS A GLOBAL
COMMUNITY TO ADDRESS THIS
PROBLEM --
THAT YOU HAVE OF ARTICULATION IS
VERY PERVASIVE.
THANK YOU THERE WILL BE
OPPORTUNITY.
WE'RE JUST ON THAT LATER TODAY --
CENTER JACKSON MANSON COPIER
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE -- AND
TO KNOW WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
STEWARDSHIP CALIFORNIA TENDS TO
LEAD THE WAY SO I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE BE.
OUT THERE FIRST IF IF WE
POSSIBLY CAN AND WITH THAT IN
MIND -- I
I'M WORKING ON THIS WHOLE ISSUE
OF FARM --
IT UNDER A BILL THAT I'VE
INTRODUCED SB FOUR TWENTY FOUR
ON EXTENDED PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY.
AND WE DID A BILL LAST YEAR DID
A BILL LAST YEAR.
ON APR --
FOUR DRUGS AND SHARPS AND I
THINK IT'S A MODEL THAT WE MIGHT
BE ABLE TO EXPAND HERE THE TEST
SAYS TO THE PRODUCERS OF THESE
PRODUCTS LOOK FOLKS.
YOU CAN'T JUST MANUFACTURE THEM
pTHERE'S THE END OF LIFE CYCLE
THAT IS REALLY CREATING.
SERIOUS PROBLEMS SO I WONDER.
WITH THAT IN MIND IF YOU HAVE
ANY THOUGHTS ABOUT IN EP OUR
APPROACH THAT IF YOU'RE AWARE OF
THE THE BASICALLY WHAT WE DID
LAST YEAR WITH THE THE
PHARMACEUTICAL INDUSTRY WE SEE
SAID HERE'S THE GOAL.
YOU'VE GOT TO YOU'VE GOT TO TAKE
BACK THESE END OF PRODUCTS AT
THE END OF THEIR LIVES AND
YOU'VE GOT TO DISPOSE OF THEM.
AND DO IT WITHOUT CHARGING THE
CONSUMER FOR IT --
AND YOU FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO IT.
AND BASICALLY WE SET THOSE
PARAMETERS AND NOBODY KNOWS
THEIR BUSINESS I WOULD SUGGEST
BETTER THAN NAY AND SO THEY WERE
ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH THAT.
THERE WAS CIGARETTE ****.
AND FRANKLY.
WHEN WE DO OUR CLEAN UP DAYS
THERE'S NO QUESTION BUT WHAT THE
NUMBER ONE SOURCE OF POLLUTION
IS OUT THERE IT'S CIGARETTE ****?
AND THOSE FILTERS THE CELLULOSE
FILTER A VERY SERIOUS PROBLEM I
I BELIEVE THEY CONTAIN
CARCINOGENIC MATERIALS THERE
THEY ARE IN OUR BEACHES THE
WILDLIFE WILL INGESTED THE
MARINE LIFE AND JUST SAID --
DO YOU HAVE ANY THOUGHTS ON HOW
WE ADDRESS THAT PROBLEM AS WELL
AS THE MORE OBVIOUS PLASTIC AND
EVEN MICRO.
PLASTICA ELEMENTS --
BUT CERTAINLY IS CIGARETTE ****
ARE AN OBVIOUS PROBLEM AND ONE
THAT PERHAPS WE CAN ADDRESS
THROUGH THE E. P. R. PROCESS TO
SHARE SOME THOUGHTS ON THAT.
KLAY YET CLEARLY CIGARETTE ****
ARE -- AS
YOU MENTIONED THE NUMBER ONE
ITEM THAT'S PICKED UP IN COASTAL
CLEANUP DAYS AND ARE PERVASIVE
THROUGHOUT OUR BEACHES SO AND I
THINK A COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH
TO ADDRESSING.
PLASTICS IS GONNA BE THE MOST
IMPORTANT AND ONE THAT IS THAT
[inaudible]
SCIENTIFICALLY.
VALID IN REAL FAST AND THAT --
IS IMPLEMENTABLE AND SCALABLE SO
YOU MIGHT NEED TO START AT A AT
A LOCAL LEVEL AND BUILD UP OR
STARTED A STATE LEVEL AND BILL
THAT NATIONALLY OR
INTERNATIONALLY.
BUT AT AT THE END OF THE DAY WE
NEED TO BE TAKING.
A MUCH BROADER APPROACH THEN --
JUST ITEM BY ITEM BECAUSE EVERY
TIME WE ADDRESS ONE ITEM ANOTHER
ONE WILL POP UP.
DO YOU THINK IF WE IF I MAY TO
THE CHAIR WHO --
CREATE THIS KIND OF U. P. R.
SYSTEM STARTING WITH CIGARETTE
**** OR SOMETHING OF THAT NATURE.
THAT IT WOULD BE APPLICABLES
THROUGHOUT THE WHOLE PROCESS I
MEAN IF THE THE WITH THE GRADE
THESE THESE PRODUCTS TO GRADE
EITHER NATURALLY OR THEY
RETAINED.
WHAT WAS IT SOME?
WAS A WHALE THAT WAS JUST CAUGHT
AND HAD EIGHTY POUNDS OF PLASTIC
IN ITS BELLY MEANS.
ARE YOU SHOW THE SLIDE OF THAT
YET I MEAN THAT TERRIBLY.
UNSETTLING TO KNOW THAT THE AND
I THINK THAT I I'D RATHER SEE US
USING THE WHAT IS IT THE LITTLE.
TRASH WHEELS OF THEN ARE --
YOU KNOW MAMMAL LIFE OUR MARINE
MAMMAL LIKE BUT I'M JUST
WONDERING IF THERE'S SOME
DIRECTION AGAIN WE TEND TO LEAD.
I KNOW --
CENTER WHITE HOUSE HE'S BEEN BIG
ON THE EPR ISSUE I'M JUST
WONDERING IF YOU HAVE SOME
SUGGESTIONS YOU MENTION A
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN I MEAN IS
THERE SOME SOME HELP YOU CAN
GIVE US HERE IN THIS?
CONCEPT.
AND I THINK WHAT WOULD WOULD BE
MOST EFFECTIVE IS IF WE COULD
SET UP A MEETING WITH YOU AND
I'M TALK IN DEPTH ABOUT KIND OF
WHAT WHAT YOUR GOALS ARE AND AND
OBVIOUSLY I I CAN'T TAKE A
POSITION ON ANY SORT OF
LEGISLATION I'M HERE.
AS PART OF THE ADMINISTRATION SO
I FEEL A LITTLE CONSTRAINED AND
BY LAW I'M NOT IT YOU KNOW IT
YEAH CAN WE HAVEN'T ACTUALLY --
VETTED THE THE THE IN SUGGEST
RACE THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE BUT
PERHAPS A CONFERENCE THAT
CONVERSATION WOULD BE HELPFUL I
WOULD BE HAPPY TO DO THAT FROM
MY PERSPECTIVE MISTER CHAIRS.
I THINK WE I THINK THERE'S THE
CASE IS WELL ESTABLISHED THIS IS
A REALLY BAD PROBLEM THE THE
PLASTICS THE ISSUE IS AS YOU
SUGGESTED WITH YOUR PRIOR
QUESTION.
HOW DO WE SOLVE IT I THINK
THAT'S WHERE WE NEED TO BE GOING
NEXT?
I THINK IF I COULD JUST ADD ONE
THING WHAT ONE OF THAT AND THE
TOPICS I MENTIONED BEFORE AND A
LITTLE EARLIER WAS.
AND THIS IDEA OF MOVING TO
DIFFERENT TYPES OF PRODUCTS
PRODUCTS IN MOVING AWAY FROM
PETROLEUM BASED PLASTIC PRODUCTS --
I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
RESEARCH AND A LOT OF INNOVATION
THAT'S GOING ON AND THAT WE
COULD BE SUPPORTING.
AND THAT WOULD MOVE US AWAY FROM
THE THE PERSISTENT PLASTICS AND
TOWARDS SOMETHING THAT IS MORE
EASILY COMPOSTABLE OR OR DEGREE
TO PAUL.
THAT'S RIGHT.
SAN ANTONIO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
I'D LIKE TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT
SOME OF THE OTHER --
PRODUCTS THAT MAKE THAT MADE.
PROVE FRUITFUL IN GOOD FOR
CALIFORNIA AT AT SOME OTHER TIME
BUT MY MY ISSUE THE ISSUE THAT'S
BEEN RAISED --
TO ME RECENTLY IS.
NOW THAT TRYING IS NOT TAKING
PLASTIC IS THE THE NEED FOR
STRAWBERRY GROWERS TO GET RID OF
THE PLASTIC THEY THEY PUT ON THE
GROUND IN ORDER TO KEEP THE
PLANTS --
SAFE I THEY USUALLY ROLL IT UP
AND THE IT WAS PART OF THE
SHIPMENT TO CHINA IT CAN NO
LONGER GO AND SO.
WE'RE GONNA HAVE A CRISIS ON OUR
HANDS IT'S IT'S DIRTY PLASTIC
IT'S GOT A LOT OF DIRT IN IT.
AND AND THERE'S NO PLACE TO PUT
IT AND IT'S LOCATED IN ON OUR
CENTRAL CAST REGION SO --
IT WE NEED TO KIND OF PUT THAT
UP ON THE RADAR SCREEN I'M TOLD
THAT THERE IS A COMPANY THAT --
THAT DOES DISPOSE OF IT AND IT
MAY BE AN INCINERATION TYPE OF
OF PRODUCT --
BUT I I DON'T KNOW ANYTHING
ABOUT IT SO IF THERE'S IF YOU
HAVE ANY INFORMATION I'D BE
INTERESTED IN FIND THAT THAT
CAME TO ME WITH IN THE PAST WEEK
AND I THINK WE'RE GOING TO NEED
TO DO SOMETHING PRETTY QUICK
BECAUSE THERE WILL BE TONS OF IT.
THERE ARE TONS OF IT I THINK
THEY THE YEAR IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT POINT WHICH IS
AGRICULTURAL.
AND WASTE AND AND IT'S
ASSOCIATION OF MARINE TO CREATE
SOMETHING THAT OFTEN PEOPLE
DON'T CONNECT --
BUT WE END UP SEEING YOU KNOW
TWIST TIES FROM AND FROM
AGRICULTURAL THAT OPERATIONS.
TENS OR HUNDREDS OF MILES AWAY%
ENDING UP IN THE OCEAN SO I YOU
RAISE A VERY IMPORTANT POINT.
OKAY REALLY DO APPRECIATE THIS
VERY INFORMATIVE --
PANEL HEARING I I WILL SAY IT IT
ALSO POINTS OF THE IMPORTANCE OF
CONTINUED INVESTMENT IN OUR
PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM
BECAUSE WE DO HAVE FANTASTIC
PROFESSORS ALL UP AND DOWN THE
STATE.
WHO DO GREAT WORK I BRING
INFORMATION TO US ABOUT THE
REALITIES OF THE WORLD?
AND SO WE DO APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY AND AND AND THE AND
THE CONTINUED WORK THAT WE WILL
BE THERE TO TRY TO ADDRESS SOME
OF THESE BIG PROBLEMS WE'VE GOT.
A ONE OR TWO SOLUTIONS TODAY
THAT WILL BE LOOKING AT LATER ON
DURING OUR OUR HEARING BUT THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION.
YOUR YOUR WORK IN THIS AREA.
ALL RIGHT OUR NEXT PANEL AS WE
MENTIONEDIS GOING TO FOCUS ON A
PLUS WHICH IS IMPACT ON MARINE
WILDLIFE AND LOCAL EFFORTS WE
LIKE TO ASK.
A DOCTOR JEFF BONE IS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE MARINE
MAMMAL CENTER TO COME FORWARD
AND ALSO MERRIAM COURTED WHO IS --
PROGRAM DIRECTOR FOR UPSTREAM.
AND WITH MY ONCE YOU ONCE YOU
GET STARTED GET A STARTED --
DOCTOR BOB.
WELL HE'S PREPARING ALL JUST LET
FOLKS KNOW THAT A DOCTOR BOMBS
THE EXACT DIRECTOR OF THE MARINE
MAMMAL CENTER WHICH IS ALSO
LEGAL.
AND HE'S BEEN EXACTLY DIRECTOR
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT
THANK YOU --
ALLEN [inaudible]
WELL IN.
MANY MEMBERS ARE OFFERED WHICH
REAL PRIVILEGE TO BE HERE AT
THIS MORNING TO SPEAK ON THIS I
AM.
I DO FEEL THE DOWNER OF THIS
DISCUSSION BUT I GOT TO SAY THAT
I AND MY MY FIRM BELIEF IS THAT
MOST OF US ARE HERE IN THIS ROOM
BECAUSE WE'RE OPTIMIST SO SO.
THERE'S THAT --
THAT SAID I COULD AND AVOID
SEEING IRONY THIS MORNING OF
WAKING UP IN A HOTEL ROOM AND
HAVING TO CLAW MY WAY THROUGH
PLASTIC TO GET TO A SOAP BAR AND
TO A COFFEE CUP SO IT'S JUST.
IT'S HARD IT'S UBIQUITOUS STUFF --
I SPEAK FOR THE MARINE MAMMAL
CENTER I'M TRYING VETERINARIAN
FOR KEEPING SCORING COLLEGES AT
UC DAVIS AND UC SAN DIEGO --
AND SPEAK FOR THE WORK THAT WE
DO WITH THE MARINE MAMMAL CENTER
BUT ALSO FOR THE BROADER IMPACTS
ON MARINE WILDLIFE SO I WANT TO
TRY IT THROUGH SOME SLIGHT WITH
YOU. TO SPEAK TO THAT I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT YOU KNOW
LEADING MARINE MAMMAL TEACHING
HOSPITAL THERE'S NO ORGANIZATION --
IN THE WORLD THAT SEES MORE
PATIENTS THAN WE DO WE FIELD
MORE THAN TEN THOUSAND CALLS
INTO OUR RESCUE OFFICE EACH AND
EVERY YEAR SO WE'RE OUT THERE
AND WHERE THE EYES.
AND EARS AND THE RESCUERS OF
THESE MARINE MAMMALS WE HAVE
FACILITY.
IN --
SAUSALITO WHICH WAS RENOVATED
BACK IN.
TWO THOUSAND NINE IN OTHER WORDS
WE'RE ALSO FIRST RESPONDERS
VETERINARIANS SCIENTISTS
TEACHERS TRAINERS THAT ANIMAL
TRAINERS BUT TRAINERS OF PEOPLE.
COMMUNICATORS PROBLEM SOLVERS
AND CONSERVATIONISTS.
THE KINDS OF THINGS THAT WE SEE
ARE QUITE DIVERSE EVERYTHING
FROM MALNUTRITION TO INFECTIOUS
DISEASES --
IN THESE PHOTOS YOU SEE ONE OF
OUR SENIOR SCIENTISTS --
LOOKING INTO THE CAUSE OF THE
DEATH OF A WHALE OFTEN SHIP
STRIKES OFTEN MALNUTRITION
CENTER IMAGE THERE IS --
AN IMAGE OF A BRAIN WHERE YOU'RE
SEEING --
ATROPHY OF TISSUE FROM THE MOLE
LIKE ACID THAT TOXIN PRODUCED BY
HARMFUL ALGAL BLOOMS.
AND VERY --
VERY --
DISTURBINGLY CALIFORNIA SEA LION
THAT IS SEVERELY SEVERELY
INJURED BY MARINE DEBRIS IN THIS
CASE --
DEBRIS FROM --
FISHING.
LINES FISHING NETS IT CETERA.
I WANT TO FOCUS ON ON PLASTICS
WHEN WE LOOK IN AGGREGATE AT THE
IMPACTS OF THE DIFFERENT THINGS
THAT CAUSE DISTRESS AND DISEASE
FOR OUR ANIMALS POPULIST IS
MALNUTRITION.
THERE IS A CATEGORY ABOUT 10% OF
OUR ANIMALS WE CAN ATTRIBUTE THE
HARM.
DIRECTLY TO HUMAN PRACTICES
WITHIN THAT CATEGORY IS MARINE
DEBRIS WILL SEE EVERYTHING FROM
ANIMALS AND TANGLED IN FISHING
LINE QUITE COMMONLY. TO
INGESTION OF PLASTICS --
AND IT'S IT'S ALWAYS VERY
DISTURBING FINDING.
LIKE SENATOR ALLEN --
I SAW THE NEWS OUT OF THE
PHILIPPINES --
THIS WEEKEND WHICH WAS
DISTURBING I ALSO TRIED IT
THROUGH WHAT THE GENERAL PUBLIC
MIGHT HAVE SEEN IN THIS PAST
YEAR AND IN THE GUARDIAN THERE
WAS THE REPORT OF A AWAY ALL
DYING AFTER EATING EIGHTY BAGS
IN THE NATIONAL GEOGRAPHIC THERE
WERE A COUPLE OF ARTICLES JUST
OVER THIS --
SAME PAST YEAR WERE SPERM WHALE
HAD INGESTED THIRTEEN POUNDS OF
PLASTIC DEBRIS AND DIED --
THERE WAS ALSO REPORT NAT GEO OF
A A DEATH OF A SEAL WITH A
PLASTIC BAG FOUND IN ITS STOMACH --
IN THE UK'S INDEPENDENT THERE IS
A REPORT OF A SEAL THAT HAD BEEN
REHABILITATED AND PHYSICALLY
DAMAGED IS ABLEBY THE
ENTANGLEMENT THAT IT HAD FACE TO
THE POINT THAT THEY COULDN'T
EVEN WRITE ITSELF.
POINT POINT BEING THAT THESE --
THESE REPORTS EVEN IN FRONT OF
THE PUBLIC ARE ARE COMMON THIS
IS A UBIQUITOUS PROBLEM THE
RESULTS IN THE IMPACTS OF IT ARE
UBIQUITOUS.
AS WELL BUT THAT'S IN THE IN THE
PUBLIC.
DOMAIN.
WENT TO THE SCIENTIFIC
LITERATURE AS WELL JUST OFFER
YOUYOU --
FOR QUOTATIONS FROM WHAT ARE
THREE DIFFERENT --
PAPERS OUT THERE BUT THE FIRST
IN JUSTIN AND TANGLE MEN AND
DEBRIS HAS BEEN DOCUMENTED OVER
60% OF ALL DOLPHIN AND WHALE
SPECIES.
OVER THE SET OVER SEVEN YEARS A
SEVEN YEAR PERIOD I SHOULD SAY
THIRTEEN SPERM WHALE STRANDED IN
ITALY WHEN THEY WERE LOOKED AT
FROM POST MORTEM POINT OF VIEW --
MARINE DEBRIS WAS FOUND IN TEN
OUT OF THIRTEEN SPECIMENS AND IT
WAS MOSTLY PLASTIC SO IT OUT
THERE IN IN THE KINDA ANECDOTAL
PUBLIC DOMAIN IT'S OUT THERE IN
THE SCIENTIFIC.
LITERATURE AS WELL AND IT'S
IMPACTS ARISING FROM UNTANGLING
CAN RESULT IN INJURY DROWNING OR
STRANGULATION AND THOSE FROM
INGESTION VERY FROM.
NO DISCERNIBLE IMPACT TO ACTUAL
BLOCKAGE OF THE DIGESTIVE TRACT
OTHERS HAVE ALREADY ALLUDED TO
WHAT WE DO AND WE DON'T KNOW
ABOUT THE PRESENCE OF THOSE
PLASTICS AS A GRANTED.
A DIGESTIVE TRACT SUB LETHAL
EFFECTS MAY COMPROMISE FEEDING
AN ASSOCIATE MALNUTRITION.
DISEASE AND REDUCED REPRODUCTION
AND GROWTH AND LONGEVITY.
SO DISTURBING THINGS JUST FROM
ONE GROUP OF MARINE ANIMALS
ALONE THOSE PAYING MARINE
MAMMALS.
SO AS A CABBIE OUT TO THE NEXT
FOR IMAGES THAT I'M GOING TO
SHOW YOU NOT BECAUSE OUR
HORRIFIC BUT BECAUSE THEY'RE ALL.
WHAT WE CALL CHARISMATIC
MEGAFAUNA THESE ARE?
THE BIG ANIMALS THAT GET OUR
ATTENTION AND AND I WOULD ARGUE
THAT -- THEY
DO AS A SERVER SERVICE IN DOING
THAT THEY THEY ARE ATTRACTIVE
THEY ARE CONVERSATION STARTERS
STATE TO ATTRACT THE IN IN
GENDER AND ILLICIT.
THE GOOD WILL OF PEOPLE IN AN
INCREDIBLE WAY THIS IS THE WIND
MONK SEAL IS ONE OF THE IMAGES
THAT UPPER SHOWED.
AS WELL ROLL ON THE BIG ISLAND
BACK IN.
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN MANY
STRESSES BASE THIS SPECIES ARE
ONLY THIRTEEN ANIMALS THIRTEEN
HUNDRED ANIMALS ALIVE IT'S
EXTRAORDINARILY ENDANGERED
SPECIES ONE OF THE THREATS IS IN
FACT.
MARINE DEBRIS.
A WHALE SHARK --
SEEMINGLY IN THIS IMAGE ABOUT TO
GOBBLED DOWN A PLASTIC BAG WITH
A MARINE DEBRIS FLOATING ALL
ABOUT ABOVE IT WHALE SHARKS IF
YOU'RE FAMILIAR WITH THEM ARE
FILTER FEEDERS.
THERE WERE MOVING THROUGH THE
WATER UP AT THE SERVICE WERE A
LOT OF THESE PLASTICS WILL
AGGREGATE SO THEY'RE BASICALLY
FILTERING IN AND TAKING IN
POTENTIALLY A WHOLE LOT OF
MARINE DEBRIS.
PLASTICS PACIFIC LEAD.
DOCTOR AL DOVE DOWN AT THE
GEORGIA AQUARIUM IN ATLANTA
TAKING CARE THE WHALE SHARKS IN
THEIR CARE BUT HE'S ALSO DOING
FIELD WORK EXTENSIVELY AROUND
THE WORLD.
GETTING BLOOD FROM WILD ANIMALS
TRYING TO CORRELATE WHAT HE'S
SEEING IN THOSE BLOOD SAMPLES
WITH WHAT THEY ARE INGESTING
FROM OTHER SAMPLES THAT THEIR
OBTAINING.
SEE TURTLES I I DIDN'T WANT TO
PUT THE THE PHOTO OF THIS
ETERNAL WITH THE STRAW IN ITS
NOSE IN HERE.
BY THAT BECAUSE I'M SURE YOU ALL
SAW IT BUT YOU YOU YOU JUST
GOOGLE SEA TURTLES PLASTIC AND
IS PRETTY HORRIFYING WHAT YOU
WHAT YOU SEE.
DAY IF YOU THINK ABOUT THE
CLASSIC --
CHALLENGE OF AN ANIMAL THAT FOR
EONS HAS BEEN A HARD WIRED TO
LOOK AT SOMETHING FLOATING IN
THE WATER COLUMN.
OF THE LOOK AND SHAPE OF A
PLASTIC BAG AND THINK IT'S A
SQUID IN GOBLET DOWN --
IMPACTED BY PLASTICS IN IN A
SEVERE AND AND SIGNIFICANT WAY.
AND THIS TOO IS IS NOT IMAGE
THAT I THINK WOULD BE UNFAMILIAR
TO YOU ALL --
CELEBRATED ISN'T THE RIGHT WORD
A TORY THIS IS A BETTER WORD AT
THE IMAGES THAT COME OUT OF THE
NORTHWEST HAWAIIAN ISLANDS --
WHERE ALBATROSS OUR OUR WE WILL
FOR THE IMPACT OF OF PLASTICS ON
WILDLIFE I THINK IT WAS PART OF
WHAT --
SPURRED --
DAVID ATTENBOROUGH TO TWO
DECLARED THE THE IMMENSITY OF
THE PROBLEM WITH PLASTICS A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO AS HE WAS
CITING WHAT HE WAS WITNESSING
WITH --
ALBATROSS IS COMING BACK TO TO
PROVIDE LET'S DO OF THINGS LIKE
THIS. TO THEIR CHECKS.
SO MACRO PLASTICS MICRO PLASTICS
AB HAVE BEEN --
DISCUSSED HERE THIS MORNING
ALREADY.
SENATOR STERN HAD ASKED THAT THE
VERY VERY APPROPRIATE QUESTION
OF WHERE IT IS THE SCIENCE IN
AND MY MY COLLEAGUE I'M TO MY
RIGHT MIGHT MAY HAVE MORE
INFORMATION ON THIS.
FROM WHERE I SIT THE THERE'S SO
MUCH BETTER AND UNDERSTANDING OF
THE IMPACT ON WILDLIFE FROM A
MACRO.
PERSPECTIVE.
AND YET I I SAID IN AN
ORGANIZATION WHERE WE SEE
HUNDREDS OF ANIMALS EACH AND
EVERY YEAR --
WE ARE INVESTIGATING THE DEATHS
OF THOSE ANIMALS FOR THE
PROXIMATE CAUSE.
BUT WE HAVE IN FRONT OF US AS A
STUDY RESOURCE A SAMPLE RESOURCE
OF A AMEND CITY AND
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE OURS THIS IS
MY AND MY MY CHALLENGE MYSELF.
NEED TO ALLY WITH OTHER
INVESTIGATORS TO START
UNDERSTANDING WHAT IS TRANSITING
TO THE GUTS OF ANIMALS WHATEVER
THEIR OTHER BECAUSE OF DISEASE
MIGHT BE.
AND HOW DO WE GET TO UNDERSTAND
BEING THAT'S BEING ABSORBED BY
THOSE ANIMALS.
AND OR OTHER EFFECTS OF OF THEIR
PRESENCE IT'S NOT WELL
UNDERSTOOD FROM WHERE I SIT YET
AND NOW.
ANY ONE OF US WOULD SAY THIS
CANNOT BE GOOD.
SO PLASTICS IMPACT IN THIS IS IN
CLOSING IN THE CONTEXT OF OTHER
THREATS TO MARINE WILDLIFE THE
THREATS ARE MANY TO MARINE
WILDLIFE'S THE THE SAMPLE WE SEE
IS SPECIFICALLY MARINE MAMMALS
ON THE WEST COAST WHERE WE SEE.
MALNUTRITION FACTS DISEASES
CANCER EVEN [inaudible]
AND YET.
THE ISSUE OF PLASTICS IS ONE
WHERE IT SEEMS.
WE HAVE THE THE MOST CLEAR
RESPONSIBILITY AND AND PERHAPS
HAVE THE THE THE POLITICAL WILL
BECAUSE OF THAT AND BECAUSE OF
THE CHARISMA OF THESE ANIMALS.
TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE SO --
THESE OTHER THESE OTHER ISSUES
THAT WE FACE IN CARING FOR
MARINE MAMMALS.
ARE GOING TO OCCUR THERE IS
ALWAYS GOING TO BE MALNUTRITION
BASED ON THE AND THE DIVERSITY
OF SEASONS IN THE PLENTY OR LACK
OF FOOD.
RESOURCES THERE'S ALWAYS GOING
TO BE INFECTIOUS DISEASES THIS
IS A MAN MADE ISSUE THAT WE
INTRODUCED.
WITHIN THE LAST --
HUNDRED PLUS YEARS WE OUGHT TO
BE ABLE TO DO SOMETHING TO
ADDRESS IT.
AND I WILL CLOSE THEIR WITH A
APPRECIATION FOR THE
OPPORTUNITIES BIG REPORT THIS
MORNING.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH TALK ABOUT REALLY FIRST
YEAR THAT'S ALMOST.
YEAH.
ALMOST LESS THAN A HUNDRED YEARS
AND IT'S REALLY EXTRAORDINARY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK I NEWS --
FROM UPSTREAM WHICH SAID. SIX
THIS PART INNOVATIVE SOLUTIONS
TO PLASTIC POLLUTION. FOR A
THROW AWAY FREE WORLD.
AND SHE'S HAD A CAREER LONG
INTEREST IN REDUCING TOXICS AND
POLLUTION.
I SHE WAS FOR PREVIOUSLY --
CALPERS DIRECTOR FOR CLEAN WATER
ACTION WHERE SHE PLAYED
IMPORTANT ROLES IN THE LUNCH OF
RETHINK DISPOSABLE WHICH IS
HELPING FOOD SERVICE OPERATIONS.
MOVED TO THROW A FREE OPERATIONS
AND SO WERE VERY PRESERVE
AFFIRMING YEAR AND HER EXPERTISE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NINE TEARS
ALLEN AND STERN --
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEES I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR PRIORITIZING
THESE ISSUES --
AND HI I WANT TO TURN FROM THE
BOMBER OF THE PROBLEM TOO I'M
MORE OPTIMISTIC VIEW --
FOCUSING ON THE SOLUTIONS --
I'VE BEEN FOCUSING ON SOLUTIONS.
AND HOW WE SOLVE THIS PROBLEM
EVER SINCE --
WHEN I WAS WORKING AT THE
CALIFORNIA CO I RAN INTO CAPTAIN
CHARLES MOORE AFTER HIS FIRST
DIRE JOURNEY INTO THE PACIFIC
OCEAN -- AND
FOUND AND HE SHOWED ME AS
SAMPLES WHERE YOU FOUND SIX
TIMES MORE PLASTIC THAN PLANKTON.
ON THE SURFACE OF THE PACIFIC
OCEAN AND EVER SINCE THEN THAT
WAS LIFE CHANGING EXPERIENCE FOR
ME AND EVER SINCE THEN I'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE FOR THE
LAST FIFTEEN YEARS --
MOVING FROM THE STATE TO THE NGO
COMMUNITY AND SEEKING SOLUTIONS
ON I BEFORE I MOVED OVER --
TO TALKING ABOUT UNPLUGGING
CALIFORNIA'S WHAT IS FROM
PLASTIC ILLNESS SAY WE'VE BEEN
FOCUSING A LOT TODAY ON THE
PROBLEM IN THE MARINE
ENVIRONMENT BUT THERE ARE
QUESTIONS ABOUT HEALTH.
AND I WON OFFERED THIS --
THIS ISN'T JUST A PROBLEM IN THE
MARINE ENVIRONMENT PLASTICS
SURRENDERING OUR FOOD CHAIN --
NOT JUST FROM SEAFOOD IT'S IN
ALL MANY OTHER FOOD SOURCES IT'S
IN THE AIR WE BREATHE IT'S IN
OUR TOP WATER IT'S AN R. BOTTLED
WATER -- AND
SO -- IRVING
TOWARDS FIGURING OUT HOW OLD
THIS IS EFFECTING A PUBLIC
HEALTH THERE'S ALSO HUNDREDS OF
CHEMICALS --
THAT OUR ENDOCRINE DISRUPTORS
AND CARCINOGENS IN PLASTICS AND
IN FOOD PACKAGING TO THAT END UP
STREAM IS CONVENING.
AN INTERNATIONAL CONFERENCE IN
JUNE ON LAUNCHING TO SCIENTIFIC
CONSENSUS STATEMENTS ABOUT THE
HEALTH EFFECTS OF PLASTICS
THEMSELVES AND MICRO AND NANO
PLASTICS --
AS WELL AS FOOD PACKAGING
CHEMICALS AND I WOULD BE HAPPY
TO WORK WITH THE COMMITTEES ON
ORGANIZING A PANEL ON THE HUMAN
HEALTH EFFECTS OF FOOD PACKAGING
CHEMICALS AND PLASTICS --
BUT TODAY WANT TO FOCUS MORE ON
SOLUTIONS AND TO MACRO PLASTICS --
FIRST A LITTLE BIT ABOUT MY
ORGANIZATION WE ARE --
WE'RE FOUNDED IN TWO THOUSAND
AND THREE IS THE PRODUCT POLICY
INSTITUTE WE FOCUSED ON WHAT W
DO WITH PRODUCTS AT THE END OF
THEIR USEFUL LIFE AND WE WERE
PROMOTING EXTENDED PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY FOR ALL KINDS OF
PRODUCT CATEGORIES --
AND SUCCESSFULLY AND A HELP
FOUND THE CALIFORNIA PRODUCT
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL AND HAVE
BEEN INVOLVED IN MANY EPR LAWS --
BUT WHEN WE GOT TO THE PLASTICS
AND PACKAGING IT.
HAS BECOME CLEAR TO US THAT IF
MANAGEMENT APPROACH JUST DOESN'T
REALLY --
IT'S NOT THE BEST APPROACH FOR
PRODUCTS THAT WE USE IN A MATTER
OF MINUTES AND THAT HAVE
ENORMOUS ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT
FROM THE EXTRACTION OF RESOURCES
TO THEIR CARBON AND CLIMATE
FOOTPRINT TO THEN THE TOXICS AND
PLASTIC POLLUTION.
THAT WE END UP WITH --
SO WE HAVE BEEN FOCUSING MORE ON
HOW TO WE OF UPSTREAM LOOK AT
THESE PRODUCTS AND DEVELOP
BETTER POLICIES AND THAT ENTAILS --
REALLY CHANGING MARK THROWAWAY
CULTURE.
AND THAT'S WHERE WE ARE NOW
SUGGESTING ARE HOW WE SOLVE
THESE PROBLEMS --
LOOKING AT IT FROM A CALIFORNIA
PERSPECTIVE WE REALLY ALL OF OUR
SOLUTIONS SHOULD BE SCIENCE
BASED AND GUIDED BY DATA AND SO
THE BACK AS THE OPC LITTER
STRATEGY ACKNOWLEDGES THE BEST
DATA SET THAT WE HAVE IS THE
DECADES WORTH OF CALIFORNIA
COASTAL CLEANUP --
DATA AND FROM NINETEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT TO TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE
TOP TEN PRODUCTS ARE ARE LISTED
HERE.
AND YOU CAN SEE THAT CIGARETTE
**** ARE NUMBER ONE THEY ALWAYS
HAVE BEEN --
BUT SEVEN OUT OF THE TEN TOP
PRODUCTS OR FOOD AND BEVERAGE
PACKAGING RELATED --
AND SO WHAT DO WE REALLY NEED TO
BE LOOKING AT THOSE PRODUCTS AS
A WHOLE ALL RATHER THAN TRYING
TO PICK OFF.
ONE MEAN A ONE PRODUCT AT A TIME
AND DEVELOPING MORE
COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGIES I WANT
TO POINT OUT THAT --
SO I'VE --
PUT IN READ ALL THAT ARE --
FOOD AND BEVERAGE RELATED --
I WANT TO POINT OUT THAT --
WHILE BAGS WERE NUMBER FOUR IN
THAT TIME PERIOD AS OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN BAGS ARE NO LONGER IN
THE TOP TEN AND THAT IS A
DEMONSTRATION THAT THAT POLICY
THAT WAS --
THAT EMERGE FROM THE GROUND UP
THAT WAS STARTED IN SAN
FRANCISCO IN TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVEN THE BAG.
PLASTIC BAG BAN AND THE CHARGE
THAT WORKS THAT SON YOU KNOW AS
AS YOU ALL KNOW IT'S A STATEWIDE
POLICY NOW --
AND AND THAT IS A GOOD CASE --
FOR HOW TRANSITIONING TO RE USE
AND PREVENTION --
AND BANDS OFTEN ARE A VERY
HELPFUL SOLUTION --
SO I WOULD SAY THAT WE NEED TO
BE LOOKING AT THE STATUS THAT WE
NEED TO PRIORITIZE CIGARETTE
****.
AND AND CAPS AS A SEPARATE ISSUE
BECAUSE THERE'S A GOOD SOLUTION
FOR THEM AND FOOD WHERE AS A
GENERAL.
ISSUE AND THEN MICRO FIBERS ARE
NOT COUNTED OBVIOUSLY IN COASTAL
CLEANUP BECAUSE THEY'RE TOO
SMALL THEIR MICRO THANK YOU --
BUT THEY ARE THEY HAVE EMERGED
AS ANOTHER VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE
AREA WHERE WE NEED SOLUTIONS.
SO AS WE CRAFT SOLUTIONS WHAT
WHAT IS A FRAMEWORK FOR THINKING
ABOUT THE BEST SOLUTIONS --
FOR THESE PRIORITY PRODUCTS AND
LET ME SUGGEST THIS IS A
FRAMEWORK THAT WAS ALSO --
REITERATED IN THE OCEAN LATER
STRATEGY BECAUSE THERE'S GENERAL
AGREEMENT AMONGST OF THE PLASTIC
POLLUTION COMMUNITY AND THE
REGULATORS ON THIS APPROACH.
ON A VERY MUCH HAILS FROM MORE
THREE OURS --
SOLID WASTE HIERARCHY THE IDEA
THAT WE SHOULD REDUCE AND
PREVENT AS MUCH OF THIS SINGLE
USE THROW AWAY STUFF AS POSSIBLE
AND THEN WORRY ABOUT --
AND THEN FIGURE OUT WHAT WE DO
WITH THE REST OF IT.
SO SOURCE REDUCTION OR
PREVENTION STRATEGIES INCLUDE
PRODUCT BANS.
MINIMIZING SINGLE USE AND REUSE
OR REDUCTION SORRY MESS THAT AND
THEN --
SECOND THEN AFTER WE'VE DONE
THAT AND THAT COULD INCLUDE
THINGS LIKE MINIMIZING
DISPOSABLE PACKAGING LIKE IN ASK
FIRST POLICY FOR STRAWS OR
REPLACING DISPOSABLES WITH
REUSABLE AS AS ARE BAD --
POLICY HAS DONE AND AND CHARGING
FOR CHARGING FOR PRODUCTS BUT
FOR THOSE THAT WE CAN'T REDUCE
THEN THERE ARE THE CONTROL
MEASURES LIKE A GOOD WASTE
MANAGEMENT INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
LOOKS AT RECYCLING AND
COMPOSTING AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE.
AND WHEN WE FOCUS ON DISPOSAL WE
NEED -- TO
TO HAVE BETTER GARBAGE
MANAGEMENT TO PREVENT ILLEGAL
DUMPING AND CONTROLLING --
THIS SCAPE OF TRASH FROM
DUMPSTERS --
AND THEN THERE ARE OTHER CONTROL
I WON'T GET INTO BUT LASTLY
THERE AND THEN THERE'S A CLEAN
UP LAKE STREET WELL ST LITTER
CLEANING AND TRASH CAPTURE
DEVICES IN THE STORM DRAIN.
BUT THE REASON THAT THIS IS LAST
LITTER CLEANUP AND TRASH CAPTURE
IS BECAUSE EVERY TIME YOU CLEAN
UP A BEACH OR CLEAN THE STREET A
COUPLE HOURS LATER OR THE NEXT
DAY IT'S RE LITTERED.
SO WE'RE NOT REALLY SOLVING THE
PROBLEM AND WERE PERPETUALLY
SPENDING TAXPAYER DOLLARS TO
CLEAN IT UP --
IRATE --
DEVER HAS ALLUDED TO ALREADY
DISCUSSED SOME OF THE STATE
ACTIONS --
SO I'M NOT GOING TO WE DO HAVE
THE STATEWIDE --
STORM WATER REGULATIONS THE
TRASH AMENDMENTS THE FOCUS ON
THAT CONTROLLING CLEAN UP --
APPROACH --
AND W'VE ALSO HAD SOME GREAT
LEGISLATION IN CALIFORNIA --
THE BAG BAN.
WHEN FEE WHICH IS A SOURCE
REDUCTION MEASURE MICROBEADS AND
PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS WERE
BANNED AGAIN ANOTHER PREVENTION
APPROACH?
THE STRAWS UPON REQUEST IS A
PREVENTION APPROACH IT REDUCES
CONSUMPTION AND SENATOR ALLEN'S --
FOOD WHERE LEGISLATION THAT
REALLY ELIMINATES FOAM FOOD
WHERE --
WHICH GETS US --
TO ANOTHER ELIMINATION APPROACH --
BUT WE STILL NEED TO ADDRESS
THESE THE CIGARETTE FILTERS --
FOOD AND BEVERAGES LIKE THE
WRAPS CONTAINERS CUPS PLATES
UTENSILS AND BOTTLES.
CAPS IN LEADS AND MICRO FIBERS.
AND I WILL SAY THAT WE CAN LOOK
TO LOCAL POLICY IN CALIFORNIA
SOMETIMES OUR LOCAL.
GOVERNMENT AND LOCAL COMMUNITIES
HAVE BEEN LEADERS IN THE
THINKING ON THIS --
FOR EXAMPLE THE PLASTIC BAG BAN
ON THE FIRST ONE WAS IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVEN IN THE CITY
OF SAN FRANCISCO.
THE FIRST POLY STYRENE ORDINANCE
WAS INTRODUCED BY SENATOR
SKINNER IN THE CITY OF BERKLEY
WAY BACK IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT OKAY THANK YOU.
AND WE'VE HAD A LOT OF THE STRAW
AND UTENSIL --
BANS BANS ON PLASTIC HAVE COME
FROM THE LOCAL LEVEL TWO ITEMS
THAT REALLY HAVEN'T BEEN --
WE REALLY HAVEN'T GOTTEN INTO
STATE LEGISLATION YET OR FIGURE
ARE -- SAN
LUIS OBISPO AND CITY OF SAN
FRANCISCO BANNED THE SALE OF
PLASTIC WATER BOTTLES IN
GOVERNMENT FACILITIES.
AND BOTH SAN FRANCISCO AND
OAKLAND HAVE ALSO ATTACH FEES TO
CERTAIN --
TO LITTER ON LITTERING NO FOR
THE CLEAN UP APPROACH BUT
PERHAPS THE MOST --
GROUNDBREAKING RECENT
LEGISLATION FROM --
LOCAL GOVERNMENT IS BERKELEY'S
ORDINANCE --
WHICH I HOPE TO CRAFT --
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN WHICH IS
REALLY.
REALLY GETTING OUT THE SOURCE
REDUCTION APPROACH IT'S IS NO
DISPOSABLES WILL BE USED FOR ON
SITE DINING IMAGINE WALKING INTO
A MCDONALD'S AND YOU CANNOT BE
SERVED ON A DISPOSABLE CUPS
PLATES AND UTENSILS.
THIS IS WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE IN
EUROPE THEY ACTUALLY HAVE IT SO
IT'S REALLY NOT THAT I MEAN THEY
ACTUALLY HAVE MAKE CAFES WHERE
THERE ARE REUSABLE CUPS AND YOU
CAN HAVE YOUR CAPPUCCINO AND
CLASS ON ON A REAL.
PLATE IN A REAL COP --
AT BERKELEY ALSO ATTACH A TWENTY
FIVE CENT CHARGE ON TAKE OUT
DISPOSABLE CUPS EMULATING THE
BAG CHARGE SAYING THAT PEOPLE
CAN BRING THEIR OWN.
THEY ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT WE
WANNA GET REUSABLE AS INTO FOOD
WHERE BUT B. Y. O. IS.
NOT A GOOD APPROACH SO THEY HOW
ARE FUNDING --
HAVE FUNDING FOR THE REAR YOU TO
GO AND GET A TAKE OUT.
MEAL IN A REUSABLE PACKAGE THAT
IS PROVIDED BY THE BY THE
BUSINESS ITSELF.
IT BANS A SOME OF THE WORST
CHEMICALS IN FOOD WHERE
FLUORINATED SUBSTANCES AND IT
ALSO -- SAYS
THAT ALL DISPOSABLES MUST BE
COMPOSTABLE IN BERKELEY BUT
ACTUALLY COMPOSTABLE NOT JUST
CERTIFIED BUT IT ACTUALLY DOES
BREAK DOWN IN BERKELEY'S COMPOST
FACILITY.
ON THIS IS A REALLY GOOD A MODEL
AND WE ARE GOING TO SEE I THINK
MORE AMBULATION OF THIS IN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT IN CALIFORNIA --
UPSTREAM CONVENE TO A IN
DECEMBER A WORKSHOP FOR BAY AREA
ZERO WASTE AND STORM WATER
PROGRAM OPERATORS AND THE
CONCLUSION OF THAT WORKSHOP.
THOSE LOCAL GOVERNMENT --
STAFF SAID TO US --
WE THINK THAT REALLY IS THAT
WHAT WE NEED IS TO HAVE MORE
POLICIES THAT FOCUS ON REDUCING
DISPOSABLES.
AND WE ALSO NEED THE
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR RE USE A SO
THEY ARE PRIORITIZING AND
WORKING WITH US ON TRYING TO
DEVELOP A REGIONAL REUSABLE CUP
AND CONTAINER PROGRAM IN THE BAY
AREA.
SO THAT INSTEAD OF US CONSUMER A
WHOLE BACKPACK FULL OF REUSABLE
PRODUCTS THAT THEY WILL BE
AVAILABLE ON DEPOSIT WHEN YOU GO
TO TAKE OUT.
YOUR COFFEE OR TAKE OUT A MEAL --
SO I THINK THESE ARE THE KINDS
OF INNOVATIVE APPROACHES THAT WE
NEED AND I ALSO WANT TO SAY THAT
IT CAN BE EXTREMELY GOOD FOR
BUSINESS I AM THE HI I WHEN I
WAS A EXECUTIVES.
THE DIRECTOR OF CLEAN WATER
ACTION CALIFORNIA I CREATED THE
RETHINK DISPOSABLE PROGRAM.
THAT DEBORAH WAS TALKING ABOUT
IN ALAMEDA AND THAT PROGRAMS
WORK TO A THREE HUNDRED
BUSINESSES SO FAR --
ON VOLUNTARILY REDUCING SINGLE
USE AND EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THEM
100% OF THE PARTICIPANTS HAS
SAVE MONEY.
BY DOING THINGS LIKE --
THE UNIVERSITY SAN FRANCISCO DID
IN THEIR CAFE REPLACING
DISPOSABLES WITH REUSABLE IS AND
JUST REDUCING SINGLE USE AND
I'LL JUST SAY IT CAN HAVE
ENORMOUS FINANCIAL BENEFITS THAT --
CAFETERIA IS SAVING NOW A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR AFTER THEIR
OPERATION AND MAINTENANCE AND
SET UP COSTS ARE ACCOUNTED. FOR
TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND POUNDS
AWAY POINT SIX MILLION
DISPOSABLE ITEMS REDUCE PER YEAR.
AND A CARBON REDUCTION OF TEN
METRIC TONS PER YEAR SO THIS
KIND OF SOLUTION CAN MAKE REALLY
GOOD FINANCIAL CENTS FOR
BUSINESSES.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU GREAT GREAT GOOD WORK
AND AND CERTAINLY OF A HINT OF
OPTIMISM IN A A HEARING THAT
IT'S BEEN A LITTLE A LITTLE
DEPRESSING.
SO LET ME --
OPEN UP THE FLOOR TO QUESTIONS
THOUGHTS.
COMMENTS FROM THE THE MEMBERS.
WERE A LITTLE --
YAHIA APPRECIATE THAT BECAUSE
IT'S HARD TO LOOK AT WHAT WE IS
PEOPLE OF DONE TO UNDERMINE THE
HEALTH OF OUR SISTER AND BROTHER.
MEMBERS OF THE PLANET --
BUT AS FAR AS CLEARLY THERE ARE
THINGS WE CAN DO AND I
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT.
THE PEOPLE'S REPUBLIC OF
BERKELEY FREQUENTLY TAKES THE
LEAD ON THESE THINGS --
BUT IS OFTEN ISOLATED BECAUSE
IT'S VIEWED AS BEING SOME KIND
OF LEFT THE WHO KNOWS WHAT.
EXPLANATION FOR HOW WE RESOLVE
OUR PROBLEMS I'M WONDERING ARE
THERE ANY STATISTICS TO
DEMONSTRATE NOT JUST THAT IT'S
GOOD FOR THE PLANET.
BUT THAT --
THERE ARE BUSINESS OPPORTUNITIES
SOME OF OUR FRIENDS ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE AISLE AND PERHAPS
EVEN IN OUR OWN.
PARTY OF WANNA KNOW WHAT THE
WHAT THE PROFIT.
OR LOSS IS GOING TO BE FOR A
BUSINESS OR FOR COMMUNITY IN
TERMS OF DOLLARS. FOR IT --
TRYING THESE OTHER TO GET RID OF
PLASTICS TO GET RID OF OF THESE
KINDS OF MATERIALS THAT ARE
CREATING THE THE WAY.
THE WASTE IN THE GARBAGE THAT'S
PERMEATING OUR OUR WORLD TODAY.
DO YOU HAVE ANY THOUGHTS ON WELL
I CAN I CAN GIVE YOU SOME
STATISTICS A BIT OF FEEDBACK
FROM THE RETHINK DISPOSABLE
PROGRAM --
SO WORKING WITH OF TO THE
INDEPENDENT SORT OF MOM AND POP
FOOD BUSINESS BRICK AND MORTAR.
OF FOOD SERVICE OPERATOR IS
SAVING ANYWHERE FROM TWO TO TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR JUST
THROUGH VOLUNTARILY --
REDUCING SINGLE USE AND THEN --
I GAVE YOU AN EXAMPLE OF AN AN
INSTITUTIONAL CASE STUDY THE
UNIVERSITY OF SAN FRANCISCO --
YOU KNOW SAVING.
A HUNDRED AND TWENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR SO --
I THINK I THINK THE POINT I WANT
TO MAKE IS THAT MOST FOOD THE
FOOD SERVICE INDUSTRY DOES NOT
UNDERSTAND HOW MUCH MONEY
THEY'RE SPENDING ON DISPOSABLES.
OF ERROR IT'S VERY CONVENIENT TO
USE DISPOSABLES AND EVERYONE
THINKS THAT RE USE SWITCHING
BACK TO WHAT SOME OF US.
SOME OF US IN CERTAIN
GENERATIONS REMEMBER AS THE WAY
WE USED TO GET OUR FOOD SERVED
IN SCHOOL ON REAL PLAYED SOME
REAL.
CUPS -- AND
THE WAY WE USED TO BE SIR DONALD
CREATED THE THE TO THE TRASH
FILLED ME ALL THAT'S CALLED FAST
FOOD -- THAT --
PEOPLE THINK THAT GOING BACK TO
DISH WASHING AND GOING BACK TO
RE USE IS GOING TO COST A LOT OF
MONEY.
BUT I SET OUT TO INVESTIGATE
THAT WHEN I SET UP REFILL
DISPOSABLE AND PROGRAM HAS
PROVEN THAT ACTUALLY GOING BACK
TO RE USE AND BEING.
MINDFUL ABOUT HOW WE CAN
MINIMIZE PACKAGING SAVES
BUSINESSES MONEY.
I THINK THAT WOULD BE IMPORTANT
INFORMATION TO PROVIDE US OF FOR
THOSE WHO.
A NOT NECESSARILY MOVE BY JUST
OUR LACK OF CARING AND
RESPONSIBILITY.
FOR GOD'S OTHER CREATURES --
AND AND FOR OUR OWN HEALTH.
THE THAT EXISTS WITH SOME OF
THESE MICRO FIBERS AS WELL AS
JUST PLASTICS HAVING A AN OIL
PETROLEUM BASED TO THEM --
IT WOULD BE HELPFUL TO TO BE
ABLE TO PUT INTO DOLLARS AND
CENTS WHAT THE WHAT THE COST IS
AND HOW THERE IS A POTENTIALLY A
MUCH GREATER SAVINGS WE USE --
POTENTIALS CAN I JUST ADD ONE
MORE THOUGHT I SAW SENATOR HOLE
HOLDING UP THE COMPOSTABLE CUP
[inaudible]
YEAH WHEN.
WHAT'S YOUR QUESTION I MAY AND I
KNOW THAT THANK YOU.
WHICH IT YOU MENTIONED AND I WAS
WATCHING YOUR PRESENTATION IN
THE OTHER ROOM THE THE ISSUE OF
RECYCLABLE OR DISPOSABLE BUT NOT
REALLY DISPOSABLE THEY DON'T WHY
THEY DON'T.%
AND A FOLLOW THE THAT THE NORMAL
TRACK FOR THIS IN THIS ONE SAYS
COMBUSTIBLE A COMPOSED OF FULL.
EXAMPLE A BOTTLE YOU GOT A
PROBLEM IS THAT IS WHAT WOULD
MADE FROM CORN AND IT SURE LOOKS
LIKE PLASTIC TO ME BUT IS THIS
SOMETHING THAT IS.
COMBUSTIBLE.
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION --
FIRST WELL I JUST WANT TO SAY TO
TO PUT THAT IN THE CONTEXT OF
ECONOMICS.
THESE ARE MUCH MORE EXPENSIVE
AND THE RESULT OF OUR PHONE BANS --
WELL THAT'S GOOD FOR THE MARINE
ENVIRONMENT GETTING FOAM OUT OF
THE ENVIRONMENT IS REALLY GOOD
FOR THE FOR THE SPEAKER SYSTEM --
IT'S TURN IT IS OR HAVE TO BEAT
MOSTLY OF TO BE RECYCLABLE OR
COMPOSTABLE AND THAT'S ABOUT.
A TEN TIMES THE COST OF WHAT IS
REPLACING SO WE'RE DRIVING UP
COSTS FOR FOOD BUSINESSES --
THESE THINGS HAVE TO BE
CERTIFIED AS COMPOSTABLE
PLASTICS THAT ARE.
THAT CLAIM TO BE COMPOSTABLE
COURTING A CALIFORNIA LAW HAVE
TO BE HAVE TO HAVE CERTIFICATION --
AND SO THEY MAY BE TECHNICALLY
COMPOSTABLE IN.
A LABORATORY SETTING BUT WHAT WE
ARE HEARING FROM THE COM POSTERS
IS -- AND
I'M TALKING TO THEM IN ALAMEDA
COUNTY AND MARIN COUNTY WE HAD
THE OREGON COMPOST OR IS AS A
WHOLE GROUP CAME OUT WITH THE
STATEMENT THAT.
A LOT OF THIS BIO PLASTICS STUFF
THAT'S MADE FROM CORN AND OTHER
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTS WHILE IT
IS PLASTIC.
IS NOT ACTUALLY DEGRADING IN
MANY COMPOST COMMERCIAL COMPOST
FACILITIES AND SO IT ENDS UP
GETTING IT ENDS UP EITHER
CONTAMINATING THE GOOD ORGANIC
COMPOST.
OR IT ENDS UP JUST BEING SCREEN
END OR IT ENDS UP BEING SCREENED
OUT AND SENT TO LANDFILL ANYWAY
SO THE PROBLEMATIC PRODUCTS HAVE
BEEN.
ON THE CUP BIO COPS BIO BAGS THE
UTENSILS AND THE BIO PLASTIC
FOOD CONTAINERS --
THESE ARE THE THINGS THAT HEY
THAT MANY OF THEM NOT ALL OF
THEM BUT MANY OF THEM ARE
TELLING US JUST THEY'RE JUST
ACTUALLY NOT TO GRADING IN THE
REAL WORLD SETTING.
SO EITHER HAVE TO BE DESIGNED
BETTER OR WE NEED TO FOCUS MORE
ON WE USE LAST QUESTION IF I MAY.
SO IF -- IF
WE REALLY WANT A LOT OF PEOPLE
REALLY WOULD LIKE TO PARTICIPATE
AND I SUSPECT THAT'S THE REASON
THAT WE WENT TO THESE DIFFERENT
KINDS OF OF A CUP SAID
APPARENTLY ARE NOT ANY BETTER.
OR IT MORE EXPENSIVE FOR THE
STATE NOT ANY BETTER FOR THE THE
ENVIRONMENT --
ARE THERE --
PLACES TO GO WHERE WE CAN.
YOU KNOW MAKE THOSE CONSUMER
BASE DECISIONS BASED UPON ACTUAL
FACTS ABOUT PRODUCTS THAT.
WE CAN REUSE AND AND RECYCLE
THAT ARE GOING TO BE.
ACHIEVING THE GOALS THAT WE WANT
THEM TO ACHIEVE DO WE NEED TO DO
SOMETHING LEGISLATIVELY ON THAT
I MEAN OTHERWISE.
IF I COULD TAKE A LOOK AT THAT
IT TO IT HAS ALL SORTS OF GOOD
STUFF ON IT GREEN STRIPE BY
EAGLE PRODUCTS AND THERE'S A BIG
EGO THING ON HERE I MEAN.
I THINK MANY OF US USUALLY ISN'T
THINK WE'RE DOING A GOOD SERVICE
BUT WE'RE NOT SO WHAT DO WE DO
TO TRY TO PUT US BACK ON THE
RIGHT PATH.
GIVE ME TAKE.
WELL.
I MEAN I THINK IF WERE.
IT'S ONE THING TO GET CERTAIN
IT'S ONE THING TO HAVE SOMETHING
THAT WORKS IN A LABORATORY
SETTING BUT AS I SAID WE NEED
PRODUCTS THAT WORK IN A REAL
WORLD SETTING SO I THINK WE NEED
TO GO BACK.
WE NEED TO INVOLVE THE CALM
POSTERS IN I AM LOOKING AT THOSE
STANDARDS AND AND THE BUT MY OWN
PERSONAL FEELING FRANKLY IS THAT.
THE AG THAT.
GROWING CORN AND GROWING
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTS CAN BE
JUST AS HARMFUL AS EXTRACTING
PETROLEUM.
I MEAN IT REQUIRES A HUGE AMOUNT
OF FERTILIZER ENERGY WATER AND
TRANSITIONING ALL THAT PLASTIC
TO OUR AGRICULTURAL SYSTEMS WILL
HAVE ENORMOUS CLIMATE IMPACTS
AND WATER IMPACTS AS WELL.
SO WHILE I THINK IT IS IMPORTANT
FOR US TO DEVELOP COMPOSTABLE
PRODUCTS THAT REALLY COMPOSTING
CALIFORNIA.
I THINK WE ALSO NEED TO BE
PLACING.
REALLY FOCUSING EVEN MORE
SERIOUSLY ON TRANSITIONING AWAY
FROM THROW AWAY FOR THROWAWAY
PRODUCTS.
AND WE NEED POLICIES THAT MAKE
MANDATES.
THAT WE REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF
SINGLE USE PACKAGING OVERALL IN
CALIFORNIA BY CERTAIN PERCENT
KIND OF THE WAY WE HAVE ADDRESS
CARBON.
IF I COULD.
BUILT ON AN ANSWER JUST BRIEFLY
THE THE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
TIED TYING THOSE POTENTIALLY
BACK TO MARINE --
WILDLIFE HELP IN TAKING THIS
CONSIDERATION OF LEANING ON
AGRICULTURE AS AS A RESOURCE FOR
FOR PRODUCTS LIKE THESE.
I WAS TALKING TO ABOUT MARINE TO
BREEZE IMPACT ON MARINE MAMMALS
HARMFUL ALGAL BLOOMS ARE VERY
REAL THING THAT HAVE I'M SURE
THIS IS --
AND HE'S COMMITTEES ARE AWARE OF
FUELING IN THE GROWTH OF THOSE
ALLERGY.
IS AFFLUENT FROM AGRICULTURE IS
WARMING WATERS SO THE SO
SHIFTING.
FROM ONE PROBLEM TO SEE A
SEEMING SOLUTION FROM WHERE I
SIT AS I LOOK AT THE IMPACT ON
WILDLIFE COULD JUST BE.
ROBBING PETER TO PAY PAUL OR
OFFSETTING ONE TO TO THE
DETRIMENT OF THE OTHER.
YES THOUGH I MEAN I GUESS THE
WELL THE END OF THE DAY IT'S ALL
ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT THE
PRODUCTS ARE TRULY COMBUSTIBLE.
SO IT'S NOT IT'S NOT A MATTER OF
AND I I TOTALLY AGREE WITH YOU
THAT WE NEED TO REDUCE WASTE.
I AND REDUCE OUR RELIANCE ON
SINGLE USE BUT I DID THIS IS
THIS IT THERE'S THERE'S NOTHING.
IF IF WE IF WE ACTUALLY I I I I
GUESS I'LL ALL TO STICK ON YOUR
COMMENT ABOUT ABOUT HOW WE NEED
TO MAKE YOU'RE RIGHT WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THIS IS NOT JUST ABOUT --
LAB TESTING BUT THE REAL TESTING
OF PRODUCTS THERE ARE SOME
PRODUCTS OUT THERE THAT ARE
TRULY COMPOSTABLE AND AND AND TO
THE EXTENT THAT FOLKS ARE STILL
GONNA RELY ON SINGLE USE WHICH I
AGREE WE OUGHT TO START TO SHIFT
BEHAVIOR EARLY --
WE OUGHT TO BE DOING MORE AND
MORE AS AS MUCH AS WE CAN TO
SHIFT FOCUS ON THE PRODUCTS THAT
ARE.
THAT ARE TRULY IMPOSSIBLE YEAH I
MEAN LIKE THE FIBER WHERE IS IS
COMPOSTABLE IT'S TRULY
COMPOSTABLE WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT ISN'T LINED WITH PERFORM
NATIVE CHEMICALS AS A LOT OF IT
HAS BEEN FOUND TO BE YOU KNOW
THE SHINY.
RESIN COATING SHOULDN'T HAVE P.
FASTEN IT BUT I MEAN THAT STUFF
IS TRULY COMPOST OF BURRS.
YEAH BUT I I THINK YEAH THESE
PRODUCTS I MEAN THERE THERE
THERE'S THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT
THEY ARE.
THEY ARE ABSOLUTELY NOT AS GOOD
AS USING A REUSABLE --
BUT THEY'RE ALSO BETTER THAN --
THE OTHER PRODUCTS THAT ARE THE
THE MOST PEOPLE USE THOUGH
CLEARLY ON IN THE CASE OF THIS
PARTICULAR COMPANY --
TO WE WE NEED TO DO BETTER I'M I
I WILL SAY I KNOW THAT IT'S YEAH
WE ACTUALLY HAVE THESE HAVE MY
WEDDING AND THEY MELTED IN THE
SIDE SO THEY THEY SO THEY ARE
CORN I SUPPOSE.
OKAY -- ADD
CENTER SKINNER.
AND THANK YOU --
THANK YOU FOR HOLDING THIS.
INFORMATIONAL HEARING BECAUSE
IT'S JUST RORY.
VALUABLE FOR US TO STEP BACK AND
THINK ABOUT THE ENORMITY OF THE
ISSUE AND I DON'T MEAN TO SAY
THAT. TO MAKE US JUST WANT TO
BURY YOUR HEAD IN THE SAND BUT
BUT TO STEP BACK AND THINK ABOUT
THE VARIOUS --
EFFORTS WE'VE MADE OVER TIME IN
CALIFORNIA BACK IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE PASSED AB NINE
THIRTY NINE WHICH WHERE WE WERE
ONE OF THE FIRST STATES TO SET A
50%.
RECYCLING GOAL AND WHILE THAT'S
BEEN TALKED ABOUT A LITTLE LESS
TODAY.
WE WE DID THAT BECAUSE WE WERE
THEN IN A LANDFILL CRISIS AND WE
SAW THAT THE AMOUNT OF WASTE PER
PERSON WAS GROWING AND WE FELT
LIKE OKAY WE REALLY NEED TO DEAL
WITH THIS.
AND WE SHOULD BE PROMOTING%
RECYCLING FOR LOTS OF ENERGY
EFFICIENCY MEANS AND WE PROBABLY
WEREN'T THINKING AS MUCH AROUND.
OUR CARBONAND GREENHOUSE GASES
BUT WE WERE THINKING A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT MARINE WAY STE.
BUT NOW WE COME TO THE POINT
WHERE.
WELL FIRST OFF WE'VE GOTTEN SO
ON ONE THERE'S A COMPLETE MYTH
THAT IF SOMETHING'S PICKED UP
WHERE YOU PUT IT IN A RECYCLING
BIN THAT MEANS IT'S RECYCLED
THAT'S A COMPLETE MESS.
IT'S NOT.
THAT'S COLLECTION.
SO TO BE. TO ACTUALLY BE
RECYCLED IT HAS TO BE REMADE
INTO A NOTHER PRODUCT.
AND WHAT'S HAPPENED NOW IS VERY
LITTLE OF THAT WHICH WE ARE
COLLECTING IS BEING MADE INTO
WHAT ANOTHER PRODUCT PARTLY DUE.
TO WE HAVE MUCH LESS --
MANUFACTURING IN UNITED STATES
OR CALIFORNIA THAT USES ANY OF
THIS MATERIAL IN REMANUFACTURE
SO THERE ARE STILL SOME BUT MUCH
LESS.
AND WE SEND IT ALL.
TO CHINA AND ELSEWHERE WHO NO
LONGER WANTS OUR MATERIALS SO A
LOT OF THE FOCUS WHEN WE READ
OUR BACKGROUND MATERIALS IT
TALKS ABOUT.
WE ARE WHAT'S CALLED WHAT'S WORD
WHERE THEY CAUGHT.
NATIONAL SORTS SORRY SORRY SORRY
SO IN THIS FOCUS ON CONTAMINATED --
BUNDLES MEANING --
THE WHEN THE PROCESSING FACILITY --
PREPARES --
THE THE BAIL TO SELL OR TO SEND
TO CHINA IT NOW CHINA'S LOOKING
MORE CLOSELY AND WHETHER OUR
MATERIAL IS CONTAMINATED.
BUT REALLY BOTTOM LINE IS.
AS OTHER COUNTRIES BEGIN TO
PRODUCE THE AMOUNT OF WASTE PER
PERSON THAT WE DO THEY DON'T
WONDER DRUG THEY DON'T NEED IT
THEY HAVE THEIR OWN.
AND SO IF WHATEVER
INFRASTRUCTURE THEY HAVE FOR
REMANUFACTURING THEY'RE GOING TO
USE THEIR OWN.
TRASH NOT OURS.
THEY DON'T WANT OURS SO WHAT ARE
WE GOING TO DO WITH OUR IT COMES
BACK TO IS.
THE ONLY WAY WE'RE GOING TO
PROTECT OUR OCEANS.
AND YOUR THE FACT THAT.
THERE'S IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO
ADEQUATELY REMANUFACTURE.
ALL OF THIS STUFF THAT WE USE
NOW.
IS TO DROP ARE SINGLE USE
PRODUCTS.
AND THEN WITHIN THAT SINGLE USE
WHATEVER STILL HAS TO REMAIN. TO
HAVE IT EITHER COMPOSED BOTH
BECAUSE THAT IS BETTER I MEAN IT
IS.
OR OR FAR LESS BALL YOU LIKE HOW
CAN IT IT'S LIKE NOW.
WE KNOW THAT CARS FOR EXAMPLE.
WAY FAR LESS AND THEY WAY FAR
LESS BECAUSE THE MATERIALS WE
USE FOR THEM IT'S LESS MATERIAL.
FOR THE SAME PURPOSE SO WHATEVER
SINGLE USE WE'RE GONNA USE HAS
TO BE LESS MATERIAL AND THEN BUT
WE JUST HAVE TO USE WAY LESS
SINGLE USE [inaudible]
AND WE'RE GOING TO GET TO YOUR
BILL ABOUT THAT LATER WHICH IS
GREAT BUT ANYWAY I I APPRECIATE.
THE DATA YOU PRESENTED TO US AND
I APPRECIATE THE PREVIOUS PANEL
AND THE FOCUS ON OUR SEALS ARE
WHALES.
ARE --
DIFFERENT MARINE LIFE BUT I
THINK REALLY INDEPENDENT OF
WHETHER AND I I DON'T MEAN TO
SAY THIS IN ANY KIND OF CALLOUS
WAY BUT INDEPENDENT OF WHETHER
WE FEEL MOVED BY.
PROTECTING ONE SPECIES OR
ANOTHER THE REALITY IS WE ARE
BASICALLY DROWN IN OURSELVES
[inaudible]
IN.
THIS SINGLE USE MATERIAL.
AND IT IS FAR MORE THAN
PACKAGING THOUGH CERTAINLY HAS
POINTED OUT 40% OF IT IS.
SO WE REALLY IT'S JUST.
AS AS MUCH AS WE REALIZED BACK
IN EIGHTY NINE IN A FEW YEARS
AFTER THAT WE HAD TO FOCUS ON
NOW WE HAVE TO EMBRACE AND
REALIZE WE HAVE TO FOCUS ON
SOURCE REDUCTION [inaudible]
YEAH NINE COULD NOT AGREE MORE
OKAY REALLY DO APPRECIATE YOUR
PRESENTATION --
VERY VERY HELPFUL AND STICK
AROUND BECAUSE WE'LL BE HAVING
MORE DISCUSS COULD YOU FIX IT.
ALRIGHT I WANT TO ASK TO I WANT
TO CALL THE DISS --
AND CONSUL GENERAL.
ADDRESS LONERS GONNA GIVE US A
BRIEF.
PRESENTATION --
FROM INTERNATIONAL EXAMPLE --
HIGHLIGHTING THE WORK TO THE
CITY OF VIENNA HAS ENGAGED IN
WITH THE GRASS TO WASTE
REDUCTION I THOUGHT WOULD BE
HELPFUL --
IN THE CONTEXT OF OUR DISCUSSION
AND AND THEN WE'LL GO ON GO
STRAIGHT INTO PUBLIC COMMENT.
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY WELCOME
MISTER BECAUSE GENERAL.
SO MISTER CHAIRMAN IT'S YES AND
IT IS IT'S IT'S A GREAT PLEASURE
TO BE HERE WITH YOU TODAY --
I'M I FEEL VERY ON THAT I HAVE.
TO APOLOGIZE IN ADVANCE --
SO AT THIS IS BE BASED CONTINUES
RIGHT SO WE OF OF SAID I'VE AND
IT'S SENATE THAT BEN AND JUST
LAST FRIDAY AND THE SHOW THEN
THE MEDIATION SO I HAVE TO ADD
LIVE RIGHT.
AB AND OF COURSE I'M NOT SUCH AN
EXPERTISE IN I'M JUST A DIPLOMAT
SO I'M NOT AN EXPERT IN.
ENVIRONMENTAL POLICIES SUCH AS
YOU ARE SO PLEASE APOLOGIZE AND
IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS I
SHOULD BE ABLE TO ANSWER AND
THERE WILL BE A FEW.
I WOULD BE HAPPY TO GET BACK TO
YOU AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
I'M SO ADAM I AM VERY HAPPY TO
BE HERE --
OUT WE OF COURSE ME AS A AS
AUSTRIA AND AND I THINK ALL
EUROPEANS REALLY HIGHLY
APPRECIATE THE FUNDAMENTAL ROLE
THAT CALIFORNIA'S PLAYING.
AGAINST CLIMATE CHANGE AND
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION I THINK
IT'S SO IMPORTANT THAT YOU'VE
TAKEN OVER LEADING ROLE --
HE IN THE UNITED STATES AND OF
COURSE --
VIA THE SPECIALLY ABBOTT
EXPERIENCE WOULD BE DELAYED
THERE ABOUT YOU KNOW THE SPECIAL
CONNECTION BETWEEN CALIFORNIAN
OSTRANDER THE AREA.
WE ARE VERY HAPPY AND WOULD JUST
LIKE TO OFFER --
FOR OUR SERVICES IN THOUGH
COOPERATE INTERNATIONAL TO
GATHER AND IT'S NOT THAT WE
ALWAYS HAVE.
TO REINVENT THE WHEEL AND YOU'LL
RIGHTS SO WE ALSO WORK WITH
OTHER COUNTRIES AT THE CAPITOL
IS WE HAVE TO GATHER SO AT IT
THAT THERE'S A LOT OF
INTERNATIONAL XP AS AN EXCHANGE
IN THAT AREA.
IS CERTAIN THE OFF OFFICE OF THE
ESSENCE SO --
AUSTRIA'S SUCH AS BE IN --
EN ENVIRONMENTALLY VERY ACT KIND
OF CONSCIOUS COUNTRY FOR A VERY
LONG TIME.
SO -- MET
MUCH OF THE LEGISLATION THAT THE
POLICIES.
FUNDAMENTAL POLICIES GO BACK TO
THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES IN THE IN
THE IN IN THIS FIELD --
AND I I THINK THAT THE REASON IS
QUITE THE SAME IN ALL AT JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA'S RIGHT SO WELL I WAS
JUST REALLY FEEL VERY MUCH
ATTACHED.
TO THE NATURE RIGHT IT'S IT'S
LIKE IN CALIFORNIA IT'S IT'S POD
VERY IMPORTANT PART OF THE
NATIONAL IDENTITY SO WE GIVE RUN
OUT OF BEACHES SINCE. NINETEEN
EIGHTY FIVE AB SO I OTHERWISE WE
LOVE OUR MOUNTAINS.
LAKES WITH.
WE LOVE OUR RIVAS OB PLAYS RIGHT --
SO IT IS KIND OF DOES A CLOSE
CONNECTION OF OF OFT OFFICE YOU
KNOW FOSTER IS TO TO NATURE
ACTIONS.
BY HAS BE HAVE BEEN.
VERY MUCH INTERNALIZED BY THE
POPULATION BY THE POLITICIANS
BUT ALSO BY THE PRIVATE SECTOR
BY BUSINESSES AND THIS IS.
WHAT I THINK --
MAIDS ARE STILL ONE OF THE
LEADING COUNTRIES.
IN EUROPE IF NOT IN THE VOTE IN
THE IN THE IN THE FIELD OF OF OF
CLEAN TECHNOLOGIES --
ENDS AND ALSO ON THE POLICY SIDE
IN IN IN IN TERMS OF POLICY.
AB IMPLEMENTATION SO --
THAT BEING SAID I HAVE TO SAY WE
ARE FAR FROM PERFECT RED RIVER
Là THE PHONE BACK TO MAY TO DO
JUST ON THE FLY TIAS ADD TO
SACRAMENTO I READ.
A RECENT REPORT BY MINISTRY OF
THE ENVIRONMENT WHICH WAS QUITE
SELF CRITICAL RIGHT I MEAN THERE
COULD YOU AS YOU KNOW WE HAVE
WAY AMBITIOUS GOALS SET BY THE
EUROPEAN UNION ACTUALLY UNTIL
NEXT YEAR.
TWENTY TWENTY AT THE OUT IN THIS
REPORT INTERIM REPORT THAT KIND
OF GOOD NEWS AND BAD NEWS THE
GOOD NEWS FOR INSTANCE IS --
ENERGY EFFICIENCY IN AUSTRIA HAS
INCREASED DRAMATICALLY RAY
POSITIVE RIGHT --
AT THE SAME TIME --
THE EMBASSY BECAUSE THE ENERGY
CONSUMPTION THIS IS PROBABLY BAD
RIGHT.
THEN -- IT'S
POSITIVE AT THAT THE ENERGY
MAKES IN AUSTRIA IS IS QUITE
GOOD SO WE HAVE.
APPROXIMATELY --
THIRTY FIFTH 53% CURRENTLY AT
RENEWABLE ENERGY IN THE OF A
ROLL OF OF ENERGY CONSUMPTION.
AND ELECTRICITY 60% OF BY HIGH
TO APOLLO RIGHT SO THIS IS GOOD
MMHM.
OUT BAD GREENHOUSE GASES HAVE
BEEN GOING UP.
IN AUSTRIA AS WELL AND THAT'S
ALSO BECAUSE OF HEAVY TRAFFIC SO
AUSTRIAN ALWAYS REALLY AT THE
CENTER OF EUROPE SO WE HAVE.
NO SALAS WEST EAST RIGHT SO --
SO THERE ARE MANY FACTORS WE WE
CAN'T REALLY IMPLANTS ALSO RIGHT
SO WE HAVE TO BE VERY HUMBLE
RIGHT --
THERE'S NO REASON TO BRAG ABOUT
THE ANYTHING.
ABOUT THE DEBT BEING SAD --
I I BELIEVE THAT AUSTRIA IS IN
COUNTIES ARE REALLY INTERESTING
PATTON IS TO WORK WITH AND IF
YOU ALLOW YOU MENTIONED THE CITY
OF VIENNA RIGHT.
I'M A STILL I WILL FOCUS ON ON
ON ON ON THE END THAT THIS SEEMS
MAYBE A LITTLE BIT ALL BECAUSE
BECAUSE YOU I'M I'M IN THE STATE
SENATE.
AB PADS ON THE ONE HAND I
BELIEVE DEBT.
AB ALL THE CHALLENGES IN THIS
AREA WE HAVE WE HAVE TO TACKLE
THEM PRIMARILY IN THE CITY'S
RIGHTS WE AGREE ON THAT.
AND THEN A GIVEN YOU KNOW THE
DENSELY POPULATED REAS IN --
IN THE IN THE IN THE WEST OFF OF
CALIFORNIA RIGHT IT'S IF IF THE
ESEE THESE ARE NOT RIGHT BUT
IT'S IT'S A IT'S A HUGE ONE OF
THE HUGEST.
URBAN AND SUBURBAN ADMIRATION
INTO VOTES RIGHT AND I I THINK
IT'S INTERESTING FOR CALIFORNIA
TO LOOK AT THE EXPERIENCE.
OF OF CITIES.
A SOVIET MAYES IS IS QUITE AN
INTERESTING EXAMPLE BECAUSE OF
COURSE WE ARE MAYES IS QUITE
WELL KNOWN YOU KNOW BECAUSE OF
ITS HISTORY UNITED WHISKEY. FOR
FIVE ON THE G. IS THE CAPITAL OF
THE HAPSBURG EMPIRE YOUTH IS A
GREAT CULTURAL HERITAGE GREAT
CULTURAL LIFE MISS REALIZING.
CONTEMPORARY --
CENTURY EUROPEAN CD VERY
INTERNATIONAL.
I'M BAD AT ALL BE IN AS ALSO
RECEIVED BY LAW THE FIFTH
DIMENSION.
IN THE LAST DECADE --
UP AS A MODEL OF URBAN
DEVELOPMENT.
ABBAS SO.
ALL RIGHT FROM THE SERVER
[inaudible]
REVISION NICE.
BETTER THAN MY DOG ACTUALLY I
LIVE RIGHT.
IT'S THE FIRM FOR ITS ITS ON THE
MAJOR RIGHT NOW.
LOS DISCORD TO MY PRESENTATION
RIGHT THAT'S GAINES NOT.
ARRIVE VIA THE SO.
SO IT HAS REACHED IS THE IF THE
LOT OF INTERNATIONAL ATTENTION
BECAUSE IT LEADS MANY RANKINGS
FOR INSTANCE IN THE AREA OF LIVE
ABILITIES WITH ECONOMIST.
HAS RANKED THE ON THE FIRST --
IN THE MELISSA --
A AND ALSO BY THE UNITED NATIONS
IT SETS WERE AND AT THE HAVE
ACTUALLY BEEN MANY STUDIES MADE
ON THESE STUDIES YOU KNOW WHY IS
IT THAT THE CITY LIKE ME AND
THAT IS --
SO SUCCESSFUL IN LEADING AND THE
INTERESTING THING IS --
IF IT IS A LOT POOREST ON NOT
ALL RIGHTS ALSO V. N. AS QUITE
IN THE LONG TRADITION OF SOCIAL
POLICIES ITS ADDRESS.
BUT A LOT OF DEAD BOYS DOWN --
TO AT THE CUTTING EDGE.
INVASIVE FIFTY K. THE POLICIES
AND AND TECHNOLOGIES AND IF
YOU'LL LOOK EVEN DEEPER YOU KNOW
IT'S A LOT ABOUT SCREEN
TECHNOLOGIES AT THE END OF THE
DAY RIGHT SO A LOT OF THESE
TECHNOLOGIES.
I NOT ONLY GOOD FOR THE QUALITY
OF LIVING BUT THEY ALSO ALSO
COULD FIND VIOLENCE RIGHT THAT
THAT'S I THINK THAT'S THAT'S
THAT'S QUITE AN INTERESTING
MESSAGE.
AND ADAM.
IT'S IMPORTANT --
TO TO MENTION DAD'S VIANA HAS
BECOME A KIND OF A LAB.
FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
CITIES OF THE FUTURE RIGHT IT'S
IT'S IT'S WAS WAS VERY SPECIFIC
UP ABOUT TO BE ON THE IS.
THAT THE CITY ADMINISTRATION IS
WORKING WITH UNIVERSITIES
RESEARCH INSTITUTIONS ALSO THE
PRIVATE SECTOR PEAK
INTERNATIONAL CORPORATIONS TO
CHAS IT'S A CHEST AND OF THE
SIGN IN.
AND OUT TO WORK OUT WHAT COULD
THE FUTURE OF THE CITY'S BE HOW
COULD WE MAKE OUR CD SUSTAINABLE
AND AND LIVABLE AT THIS AT THE
SAME TIME AND THIS IS SOMETHING
THIS GRANT OF REALISTIC APPROACH
IS IS IS VERY.
THIS SET UP A WHOLE NEW FIFTY
DISTRICTS AND YOU KNOW BURKE ON
DECADES JUST TO YOU KNOW. TO TO
TO FIND THE RIGHT SOLUTIONS DID
WHAT'S AT THE CD TOGETHER WITH
PABNA SO IT'S UNIVERSITIES
COMPANIES IT'S IT'S WHAT.
IT IS DOING --
TO TO CHIEF THESE THESE KIND OF
CALLS TO MAKE OUR CITIES OUT
MORE SUSTAINABLE NOW I CAN'T
READ MY OWN HANDWRITING BUT
GENERAL CHAT LAST YET FOCUSING
ON WASTE IN PARTICULAR SELECT
THE RIGHT THE WASTE MANAGEMENT
ISSUES AND WELL --
THEWASTE MANAGEMENT IT'S
INTERESTING --
AT DAD'S ARM AB AB WASTE TO
ENERGY IS IT IS IT IS IT IS IT
IS A GREAT ISSUE INDIANA RIGHT
SO APPROXIMATELY IN AUSTIN 50%.
OFF THE WASTE IS RECYCLED --
ENDS SO THEY HAVE PRACTICALLY NO
FEAR THAT LANDFILLS ANYMORE AND
50% OF THE IN THE IN THE ATTIC
OF GOES INTO A GOES INTO --
IT WASTE INCINERATION PLANTS.
AT THESE WASTE INCINERATION
PLANTS IN THE END THE HOUSE SO
CUTTING EDGE THE IDEA OF
BASICALLY A VERY EXPENSIVE BUT
THE REALLY CUTTING EDGE YOU HAVE
NO VIRTUALLY NO POLLUTION SO I
WENT TO BUSINESS SCHOOL RIGHT
YOU KNOW.
ACROSS THE STREET FROM THE WAIST.
I INTO AND OF I TRANSFERRED INTO
AN ITCHY AND 40% OF ALL
HOUSEHOLDS IT MORE THAN 40% OF
ALL FALL WAS ALL HOUSEHOLDS IN
VIENNA.
OUR OF AYE AYE AYE SUPPLIED FROM
THESE OF DISTRICT HEATING OF OF
OF FROM THESE DISTRICT HEATING
SYSTEMS WITHOUT HAWKS WARDA.
AND THE AND AND HEATING AND AS
WELL AS AIR CONDITIONING SO THIS
IS KIND OF A VERY INTERESTING
SYSTEM SO --
SO IT'S TEN THROUGH --
IS THERE A GRANT CAPTURE.
RIGHT YEAH.
OKAY AND AND AND AND I AND I
JESTERS I MEAN IS IT THE THIRD
OF ORGANIC MATERIAL THAT YOU'RE.
TURNING INTO LSG.
WELL IT'S IT'S IT'S A VERY
SOPHISTICATED SYSTEM BECAUSE
THAT'S WHY I DIDN'T WANT TO
FOCUS AND I'M NOT AN EXPERT ON
THAT BUT ONLY FOCUS ON ON ON ON
ON THE ON THE ON THE ON THE
WASTE MANAGEMENT RIGHT BECAUSE
IT'S A VERY HOLISTIC SYSTEM.
LIKE WHERE OF FOR INSTANCE THE
IN THE IN THE SUBWAY SYSTEM THE
ENERGY PRODUCED IN THE BREAKING
PROCESS.
OFF THE OFF THE OFF THE YEAH IS
FED INTO THE ENERGY SYSTEM AGAIN
AND THEY KIND OF USED TO
ELECTRICITY. TO TO OPERATE THE
ESCALATE THIS ALLEYWAY THIS
ELECTRICITY AND SO ON SO IT IS
KIND OF BY THE ADAM THAT'S WHAT
I MEANT IT'S IT'S IT'S BASICALLY
A SYSTEM.
WHICH I WHICH WHICH IS A
COMPREHENSIVE RIGHT AND WHICH IS
NOT ONLY LIMITED TO A TWO TO ONE
ASPECT WHICH IS IMPORTANT OF
COURSE TWO WAY STREET.
CRAFT ALL RIGHT.
COULD NOT VERY I MEAN I KNOW
YOU'VE TAKEN A COUPLE TRIPS TO
EUROPE ON ON THESE ON THIS KIND
OF THIS WASTE MANAGEMENT ISSUE
RIGHT AND IS THERE THERE'S WHAT.
DO YOU WANNA CAN GIVE US A QUICK
EXAMINATION I I PRESUME THAT VNS
USING THAT WE HAVE THE
TECHNOLOGY. TO TO DO THE CARBON
CAPTURE IN THAT THE THE RAP
AGAINST INCINERATORS IS THAT AT
LEAST IN THE UNITED STATES WE
JUST BURN THE TRASH AND ALL THE
POLITICAL UP INTO THE AIR RIGHT
SO.
IT'S IN MY GENERATION WAS THE
CATTLE ACT AND IT BECAME THE
LEXUS I GUESS IS THE TESLA
VERSION OF INCINERATION AND IF
PRISCILLA PRESLEY WERE HERE HE'D
SAY IT'S NOT YOUR FATHER'S
INCINERATOR RIGHT. TO YOU OKAY
THESE ARE THE THESE VIENNESE
INCINERATORS PROVIDE NECESSARY
ELECTRICITY AND HEATING FOR THE
CITY BUT THEY HAVE --
ZERO CARBON EMISSIONS A RIGHT
NEAR. ZERO ZERO NOW THEY'RE
EXPENSIVE VERY EXPENSIVE THERE
IS RIGHT RIGHT --
BUT IT'S DOES IT BECAUSE IT'S AT
THE AT THE CITY SANTA YOU KNOW
THEY EVEN INCINERATION PLANTS.
BATES THOSE TO THE CITY CENTER
BUT IT'S IT'S NO --
DEAD AND COMING FROM.
A DELEGATIONS FROM HONG KONG AND
AYE AYES TALKS IN HONG KONG A
COUPLE OF YEARS BACK AND IS IT
HOW DID YOU DO THAT YOU KNOW
BECAUSE WE CABS.
HOW HOW CAN YOU IN ALL?
KIND OF OPERATE THEM YEAH IN THE
SITUATION PLANTED THE CITY OF AT
THE AT THE BE THE MIDDLE OF THE
CITY AND AND SO.
THAT IS IT RIGHT SO --
YOU HAVE TO HUGE BEST A VAGUE
SPANS OF TECHNOLOGY BUT IT PAYS
OFF RIGHT IN THE METRICS THAT
OU HAVE THAT WOULD NORMALLY.
WE DO A POOR JOB OF CALCULATING
THE EMISSIONS FROM LANDFILLS
HERE WE JUST SERVICE IT'S A BIG
CALIFORNIA SECRET WE THINGS THAT
END UP IN A LANDFILL WE KNOW
THAT THEY ROCK AND THEY GO
THROUGH.
THERE'S THERE'S NOTHING THAT IS
HE MADE A WE'RE TRYING TO
CAPTURE THAT BUT WE DON'T REALLY
SPEND TIME TALKING ABOUT WHAT
THAT.
THAT THAT EFFECT ON GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS IS YOU.
I GUESS THE QUESTION IS IS THAT.
OVERALL OUTSIDE OF VIENNA IN
AUSTRIA IS YES VIRTUALLY I MEAN
THE F. F. BEING FUNDAMENTAL
REDUCED YOU KNOW OF IN IN THE
LAST DECADE SO.
IT'S IT'S IT'S MOSTLY IT'S IT'S
ALSO SO AND RECYCLING OF WASTE
AND YOU KNOW IT IT'S IT'S A LOT
WITH BECAUSE IT'S A REYES
COMPREHENSIVES SUBJECT RIGHT.
SO IT'S UP TO AVOID WASTE THIS
IS OF COURSE THE FIRST STEP IN
THIS IS ALSO BE MENTIONED ALSO
BE MENTIONED IN YOUR DISCUSSION.
OF A SO TO TO AVOID ONE TIME USE
ITS ADDRESS SO IT'S IT'S ALL OF
THIS PUBLIC POLICY TO ADVOCATES
RIGHT INTO A TO A TOOL. TO TO
PASS LEGISLATION THAT AVOIDS --
OF OF ONE TIME AND ONE TIME USE
IT SHOULD SET TO A RIGHT AND
THEN OF COURSE IT'S IT'S IT'S
WITH CYCLING WHICH IS REALLY BIG
IN AUSTRIA.
AND TELLS A LOT OF FAR OFF TECH
COMPANIES A GOOD FOCUS ON ON ON
ON THESE AREAS.
AND THEN OF COURSE THERE'S THE
INCINERATION SO IT'S IT'S I BAY
COMPLEX PROCESS RIGHT CAN YOU
GIVE US A FLAVOR OF THE TYPE OF
RECYCLING --
THAT'S HAPPENING AT LEAST AND
PLASTICS BECAUSE YOU KNOW WE
HAVE PLASTIC BOTTLES WHICH ARE
RELATIVELY EASY TO RECYCLE
ALTHOUGH WE DO A LOUSY JOB HERE
IN CALIFORNIA AS FAR AS WE GOT A
9%.
NUMBER THEN THERE'S THESE OTHER
CONTAINERS I'LL PUT THEM IN.
DIRTY PLASTIC THERE'S YOGURT AND
MAYONNAISE AND THEY THESE TYPE
OF THING SO RIGHT THAT COME IN
THESE CONTAINERS --
AND RAPPERS --
HOW DO YOU HOW TO DOING ON THESE
SEGREGATING THE DIFFERENT TYPES
OF PLASTIC THE FIRST QUESTION
THE SECOND IS IS --
LIMITING THE THE CONTAINERS THAT
THE FREE MARKET IS USING IN THE
IN THE CITY I KNOW THAT THE U.
E. U. HAS.
A DIRECT THEM THAT THE YOU'RE
NOT SUPPOSED TO BUT JUST
HISTORICALLY WHAT IS AUSTRIA
DEAD WEIGHT WELL --
FIRST OF ALL --
YOU KNOW AB AS YOU KNOW IS IN
MANY EAST.
EUROPEAN COUNTRIES HAVE A
SOPHISTICATED WASTE SEPARATION
SYSTEM RIGHT YOU DON'T HAVE ONLY
THESE TWO BOXES OLD PAPER ANNA.
BUT YOU HAVE ONE FOR PLASTIC AND
AND ONE FOR PAPER AND ONE FOR
GLASS FOR GREEN THEIR SOCIAL FOR
FOR FOR KILEY.
GREEN GLASS FOR WHITE GLASS IT'S
ADDRESS THEN YOU HAVE KIND OF
EXACTLY RIGHT SO HERE FOR A FULL.
STEPPED UP OF THESE CONTAINERS
AT A AND AND USUALLY IT'S IT
MUST ALSO BE THERE'S ALSO IT
MUST BE INDICATED ON THE PACKAGE.
OFF THE OF THE MATERIAL IF IT'S
RECYCLE ALL NOT.
RIGHT AND AND AND YOU'RE
COMPLETELY RIGHT DID SOME IN ALL
OF IT TAKES ALSO SOME EFFORTS TO
AVOID THAT PEOPLE COLLECT TO
MATCH RIGHT BECAUSE THE DAY OF
BUT THEY PUT A LOT OF THINGS
INTO THE CONTAINER WHICH
SHOULDN'T BE DEBT OR I AM.
OR IN OUR CASE WE'RE PUTTING A
LOT OF THINGS IN THE CONTAINERS
THAT.
WERE TELLING PEOPLE TO PUT THE
CONTAINERS YET RIGHT AND OF
GETTING RECYCLE RIGHT IT'S
COMPLICATED FOR MATTER
CONVENIENCE TO SINGLE STREAM
MOST OF THE RESIDENTIAL
RECYCLING SYSTEM IN RIGHT --
THERE'S BEEN SOME SERIOUS
DOWNSIDE SAID THERE'S SOME
OUTSIDE THERE'S SOME SERIOUS
DOWNSIZE BECAUSE SO.
IT IS DISTRESSING HOW LITTLE
THAT THAT WHICH GETS DURING
THESE BEEN SENSE OF ACTUALLY
GETTING RECYCLED IN THE END OF
THE DAY.
SO WE APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR
TESTIMONY MISTER CONSUL GENERAL
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION I I KNOW I THINK
THIS IS CERTAINLY GOING TO BRING
UP SOME MORE QUESTIONS FOR
THINGS WE WANT TO LEARN FROM THE
U. ON I MEAN IT YEAH THIS
INCINERATION ISSUES
CONTROVERSIAL.
BUT BUT YOU KNOW IT'S LIKE AS AS
GERM.
WHAT CASKEY SAID YOU KNOW THE --
NOT YOUR GRANDMOTHER'S
INCINERATION AND AND MAYBE THEIR
WAYS OF DOING IT AT THE ENGAGING
IN THAT KIND OF ACTIVITY AND
MUCH MORE ENVIRONMENTALLY
SUSTAINABLE WAY THEY COULD
ACTUALLY PRODUCE ENERGY AS WE
LIVE.
IS WRITTEN AS WE MOVE ALONG SO
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE THANK YOU FOR PARTICIPATION
AND AND FOR YOUR INSIGHTS.
SO THAT WILL OPEN UP THE THE THE
THE AND ON THESE ISSUES AND I
WILL GO BACK INTO ARE YOU Q.
HEARING.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE POLITIQUE MAN.
OKAY -- I
HAVE THE HONOR OF REPRESENTING
THE SIX LARGEST PROCESSOR
RECYCLER RE KLEBER'S SO I HAVE
THE GUYS WHO MAKE BOTTLES AND
BOTTLES.
AND WORK LAST YEAR WITH SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE SKI AND SOME OF THE
ON THESE ISSUES I HAVE A COUPLE
OF POINTS TO MAKE IT WAS A
FASCINATING HEARING I'VE GOT TO
GO TO A DOCTOR'S APPOINTMENT SO
I CAN'T STAY BUT A COUPLE OF
THINGS.
ONE WHEN YOU CONSIDER WHAT IS
RECYCLABLE ISN'T BESIDES THE
FACT IT ALL GOES INTO ONE FAN.
THE THE DIAGRAM THE RECYCLING
DIAGRAM NUMBERS AREN'T CORRECT.
I MEAN THEY OFTEN HAVE ONES ON
THEM AND THEY AREN'T ONES SO
LOOKING AT THAT IS REALLY KEY.
ARE CLOSE LOOP WAS WHAT WE TRY
TO DO WHICH IS YOU TAKE A BOTTLE
OF PLASTIC ITS USE IT GOES BACK
TO OUR PEOPLE THEY MAKE IT INTO
A NEW PRODUCT IN THAT IT BECOMES
A NEW PIECE OF RECYCLED PLASTIC
OUR P. ET --
AND PART OF OUR PROBLEM IS THE
CAN LOT OF CRAPPY GOING INTO THE
SAME BàN AND THEN WE HAVE TO
SORT IT AND OBVIOUSLY FIVE TWO
SEVENS GO TO THE TOP BECAUSE
THERE'S NO OTHER USE --
FOR THAT I KNOW OF RIGHT NOW
ALTHOUGH I KNOW YOU HAVE SOME
IDEAS -- AND
THEN THE FACT OF JUST CONTINUING
LEADING VIRGIN PLASTIC COMMENDED
STATE IN CONTAINERS IF IT
DOESN'T RECYCLED IT'S JUST A
PROBLEM.
IT ISN'T YOU KNOW MAYBE IT'S
CHEAPER BUT IT'S JUST PROBLEMS
SO I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU AND THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR HAVING US HERE.
HI THERE --
THANK YOU FOR HAVING THIS
HEARING THIS IS GREAT THANK YOU
FOR TAKING PUBLIC COMMENTS.
I'M CHRISTY GAMER AND THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY COUNCIL ON OCEAN
AFFAIRS SCIENCE TECHNOLOGY COAST.
I KNOW SOME OF YOU KNOW WHO WE
ARE FOR THOSE OF YOU DON'T KNOW
WHO YOU ARE WHO WE ARE WORKING
TO CHANGE THAT --
APPRECIATED DOCTOR GORDON'S
COMMENTS ON SO WHAT SOME
UNIVERSITIES ARE DOING AND I
WANTED TO POINT OUT THAT EARLIER
THIS YEAR THE CSU.
ADOPTED A SINGLE USE PLASTICS
POLICY WHICH WILL PHASE OUT THE
USE OF ALL SINGLE USE STRAWS.
TAKE OUT BAGS AND THE SALE AND
DISTRIBUTION OF PLASTIC WATER
BOTTLES BY.
TWENTY TWENTY THREE NOW I
PERSONALLY AS AN INDIVIDUAL WISH
IT WAS ALL FASTER I'M SURE WE
ALL DAY --
BUT I DO WANT TO POINT OUT THAT
THE CSU IS THE LARGEST PUBLIC
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM IN THE COUNTRY
FOR FOUR YEAR DEGREES AND I HOPE
THAT THAT SERVES AS A MODEL FOR
OTHER UNIVERSITIES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AS WELL. ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I DID WANT TO SAY
WITH REGARD TO SINGLE USE
PLASTICS IS THAT I SEE WHEN I GO
TO THE GROCERY STORE THAT THERE
ARE STILL PLASTIC BAGS.
THAT I THINK ARE NOT TECHNICALLY
SINGLE USE BECAUSE THE PLASTIC
IS ACTUALLY THICKER.
SO THEY'RE HIGHLY DISPOSABLE.
SO I CAN ENVISION THAT HAPPENING
WITH PLASTIC WATER BOTTLES WHICH
IS ONE OF COAST BIG ISSUES --
WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT IF WE
PHASE OUT AND BANNED SINGLE USE
WATER BOTTLES THAT THE LANGUAGE
IS APPROPRIATE.
SO THAT WE DON'T JUST END UP
WITH PLASTIC WATER BOTTLES THAT
SOMEHOW ARE NOT TECHNICALLY
SINGLE USE.
THE OTHER THING I THINK WE NEED
TO CONSIDER AS WE GO FORWARD AS
THE ECONOMY AND THE ECONOMIC
IMPACT THIS ECONOMY I THINK
THRIVES TO A LARGE EXTENT ON
SINGLE USE PLASTICS AND A
DISPOSABLE ECONOMY.
I'M IN FAVOR OF THE OBVIOUSLY
CHANGING THE WAY THAT IN ORDER
TO BE SUCCESSFUL WE NEED TO
INCORPORATE THAT ASPECT OF IT AS
WELL SO WE CAN ENSURE.
PEOPLE'S LIVELIHOODS AND AND
SUSTAINABLE INDUSTRY THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING SIR ALAN AND THAT
YOU'RE STERN COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS ASHLEY LAKE --
DRINKER AND I'M THE PACIFIC
POLICY AND COMMUNICATIONS
MANAGER WITH --
SHE AND I JUST WANTED TO SAY I
THINK.
A QUICK THANK YOU --
TO BOTH COMMITTEES FOR JOINTLY
COMING TOGETHER TO HAVE THIS
INFORMATIONAL HEARING.
ON I THINK IT'S VERY CLEAR FROM
THE COMMENTS THAT YOU WITH A
LEGISLATIVE MEMBERS HAVE MADE
THIS MORNING THAT THE GLOBAL
PLASTICS CRISIS AND THE
IMPLICATIONS IN CALIFORNIA IS AN
ISSUE THAT ALL OF YOU ARE VERY.
WELL VERSED ON AND VERY
PASSIONATE ABOUT SO WE JUST WANT --
TO AS SHE AND I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP AND WE RECOGNIZE
THAT THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
PIECES OF LEGISLATION OVER
SEVERAL YEARS THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS TO ADDRESS --
SOME PRIORITY PRODUCTS WHICH IS
VERY IMPORTANT --
BUT AS I FIVE COMMENTS SOME OF
YOU HAVE MADE AND AND SOME OF
THE ON EXPERT TESTIMONY JUST
WANTED TO ECHO SOME OF THE
COMMENTS THAT.
WHAT WE REALLY NEED GOING
FORWARD IS MORE A MORE
COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTION TO
ADDRESSING THE SINGLE USE
PLASTICS CRISIS AND WE BELIEVE
THAT RECYCLING IS IMPORTANT AND
SHOULD BE PROMOTED --
BUT RECYCLING ALONE ISN'T THE
ANSWER WHAT WE REALLY NEED IS --
SOURCE REDUCTION AND OBVIOUSLY
THEIR EFFORTS --
THEY IS --
SENATOR ALLEN HIM BEING ONE OF
THE MAIN AUTHORS TO REALLY --
TACKLE THIS AND OTHERS.
THE TACKLE THE PROBLEM
COMPREHENSIVELY AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO THE CONTINUING
CONVERSATIONS THIS YEAR SO THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP.
GOOD MORNING --
MY NAME IS STEVE WILSON AND THE
CAMPAIGN'S DIRECTOR AT THE STORY
OF STUFF PROJECT. ONE OF THANK
YOU ALL --
FOR HOLDING THIS HEARING AND
TAKES VERY LEADERSHIP --
CHAIRMAN ALAN.
I HAVE OVER THE PAST YEAR HAVE
BEEN FILMING OF A MOVIE CALLED
THE STORY OF PLASTIC AND WE'RE
LOOKING AT PLASTIC POLLUTION
FROM EXTRACTION ALL THE WAY TO
DISPOSAL ALL THE WAY TO THE
OCEAN.
WE FILMED ON THREE CONTINENTS.
AND SOME OF THE MOST STARTLING
THINGS I'VE SEEN --
OUR IN OUR OWN COUNTRY THERE IS
A QUESTION BY SENATOR EARLIER
ABOUT WHAT IS THE UNITED STATES
CONTRIBUTION TO PLASTIC
POLLUTION.
AND I CAN SAY UNEQUIVOCALLY IT'S
NUMBER.
ONE AND WHY I SAY THAT IS
BECAUSE COLLECTIVELY THE
PETROCHEMICAL INDUSTRY HAS
INVESTED TWO HUNDRED BILLION
DOLLARS.
INTO ADDITIONAL REFINING
CAPACITY FOR PLASTIC FEEDSTOCKS.
THEIR PROPOSES THREE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE AS SAYING CRACKERS
AND WE ARE EXPORTING THIS TO
CHINA AND WE ARE EXPORTING THIS
TO EUROPE.
SO PLASTIC POLLUTION THAT
ORIGINATESFROM A RIVER IN THE
PHILIPPINES.
ULTIMATELY ORIGINATED FROM A THE
OHIO RIVER VALLEY OR IN
APPALACHIA OR IN NORTH DAKOTA.
WE ARE HE LARGEST EXPORTER OF
OIL AND GAS AT THIS POINT.
THE GOAL OF THE PETROCHEMICAL
INDUSTRY IS TO PUT 40% MORE
PLASTIC INTO COMMERCE BY.
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE SO IF WE
THINK ABOUT THAT THAT MEANS
EVERY GARBAGE CAN AND OUR ENTIRE
COUNTRY NEEDS TO BE 40% BIGGER.
AND I'VE ALSO SEEN WHERE THIS
STUFF GOES AND WE TALK ABOUT
RECYCLING.
AND I WAS INSERTED BY INDONESIA.
AND I WAS IN A FIELD WHERE YOU
CANNOT SEE THE GROUND ALL YOU
CAN SEE IS TREES AND SHRUBS
STICKING OUT.
AND YOU GO THROUGH THIS WASTE.
AND YOU ARE PICKING OUT TRADER
JOE'S YOU'RE PICKING OUT
STARBUCKS YOU'RE PICKING OUT A A
RP CARDS SO IT'S OBVIOUS WHERE
IT'S COMING FROM.
THERE IS NO WHERE FOR THIS STUFF
TO GO IT'S WHY CHINA CLOSED ITS
DOORS VIETNAM HAS JUST DONE IT
INDIA'S DONE IT MALAYSIA'S
PARTIALLY DOING IT --
AND SO ON AND SO FORTH THERE IS
NO AWAY AND THERE IS A MASS OF
GLUT OF PLASTIC COMING.
AND UNTIL WE FIX THE SYSTEM.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEM WE NEED TO REDUCE BY
SOURCE.
WE NEED TO INCENTIVIZE AND FIX
THE RECYCLING ECONOMICS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
IT IS AN ETHICAL TO EXPORT WAY
AND I SEE WHAT HAPPENS TO IT IS
OPENLY BURNED IT IS USED AS FUEL
AND TOFU FACTORIES.
AND PLACES WITH NO ENVIRONMENTAL
CONTROLS SO.
THE IMPORTANCE OF US TAKING A
SYSTEMIC APPROACH AND A
COMPREHENSIVE BILL IN CALIFORNIA.
WILL SET PRECEDENT. FOR THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY AND IT'S OUR GOAL
AND OUR ORGANIZATIONAL SCHOOL TO
USE THIS MODEL ON A MULTI STATE
STRATEGY SIMILAR TO WHAT WE DID
ON MICHAEL B..
CALIFORNIA WAS THE FIRST TO
ACTON MICROBEADS THEY ARE NOW
LARGELY ELIMINATED IN THE
OCCIDENTAL WORLD AND THEY ARE
CURRENTLY BEING --
THEIR PROPOSALS AS WELL IN
TAIWAN.
AND IN CHINA.
SO WHAT WE DO HERE MAKES A
DIFFERENCE I NEGOTIATED FEDERAL
LEGISLATION ON MICROBEADS.
AND I WAS ABLE TO TALK TO
LEGISLATORS IN DC AND SAY.
I DON'T CARE IF YOU PASS A
POLICY.
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA DID IT AND
THAT MEANS THAT ALL THESE
COMPANIES ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
REDESIGN. TO WHAT CALIFORNIA DID%
SO AND LESS YOU GIVE US OUR
ENVIRONMENT TO LINK WHICH I
DON'T CARE IF IT PASSES THAT'S
HOW IMPORTANT ARE STATES WORK IS
IN THIS STUFF.
SO I RECOGNIZE AND TAKING A LOT
OF TIME AND SPACE BUT I VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORTS
HERE.
AND I'M WITH YOU TO HELP IN ANY
WAY POSSIBLE AND I WILL WORK TO
GET OUR MOVIE TO THE CAPITAL
THIS SUMMER --
AND THE THINGS YOU WILL SEE IN
IT WILL CHANGE YOUR LIFE THANK
YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS --
TEN JUST LIKE WITH THE AMERICAN
CHEMISTRY COUNCIL I WILL SAY.
WITHOUT QUESTION --
MY ORGANIZATION.
MEMBER COMPANIES MEMBER MEMBER
MANY CUSTOMER GROUPS RECOGNIZE
THAT WE ARE IN A CRITICAL STAGE
IN TERMS NOT ONLY OF OCEAN
PLASTICS BUT ISSUES AROUND
RECYCLING AND FINDING DOMESTIC
MARKETS FOR THIS MATERIAL.
NO QUESTION THAT WE NEED TO TAKE
ACTION IN AND BE INVOLVED IN
THAT.
I WILL LET YOU ALL KNOW THAT
WE'RE VERY COMMITTED TO
ACHIEVING THAT OBJECTIVE
YESTERDAY I DISTRIBUTE YOUR
OFFICES A A PACKET OF
INFORMATION THAT OUTLINES.
A NUMBER OF THE INITIATIVES THAT
WE'RE UNDERTAKING ARE ONLY
VOLUNTEER INITIATIVES GLOBAL
INITIATIVES OVER ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENTS ON
INNING PLASTICS --
IN THE OCEAN A NEW RECYCLING
INITIATIVES LEGISLATIVE
INITIATIVES THAT WE'VE SUPPORT
IN THE PAST WE WERE WITH YOU
CENTER ALLEN ON A BILL LAST
SESSION ONE WORK WITH YOU ON
THIS -- ON
SB FIFTY FOUR THEY WERE GONNA
HERE IN A LITTLE BIT LATER SO I
I I WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO TAKE
A LOOK AT THOSE MATERIALS --
IF YOU HAVE QUESTIONS ABOUT THEM --
WE ARE CERTAINLY AVAILABLE TO
TALK ABOUT NOT ONLY OUR
INITIATIVES BUT NEW TECHNOLOGIES
YOU HEARD A LITTLE BIT ABOUT --
INCINERATION IN IN THE EUROPEAN --
SETTING --
MANY OF OUR COMPANIES ARE ON THE
INNOVATIVE --
FOR FRONT OF TAKING SOME OF
MOLECULAR STATE IN IN NEW
TECHNOLOGIES ARE AS HE'S ME NEW
PRODUCTS SO THERE'S A WHOLE A
WHOLE HOST OF THINGS GOING ON WE
WERE WE WERE COMMITTED TO BEING
A PART OF IT WANT TO WORK WITH
THE ANATOMY APPRECIATE JUST THE
OPTION TO MAKE.
THIS COMMENT DISTRIBUTE THAT
INFORMATION YESTERDAY --
AND AGAIN COULD YOU TAKE A LOOK
AT IT AND HAVE A CHAT FURTHER
ABOUT IT THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
HELLO CHRISTOPHER CHEN WITH THE
CENTER FOR OCEANIC AWARENESS
RESEARCH AND EDUCATION.
AND I JUST SPENT THE LAST TWO
WEEKS IN NAIROBI AT THE U. N.
ENVIRONMENT ASSEMBLY WHERE I WAS
HELPING NEGOTIATE SOME OF THE
RESOLUTIONS ON PLASTICS. FOR THE
WORLD'S HIGHEST LEVEL DECISION
MAKING BODY ON THE ENVIRONMENT.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT CAME FROM
THIS WAS A JOINT DECLARATION
MINISTERIAL DECLARATION BY THE
MINISTERS AND HEADS OF STATE OF
ALMOST TWO HUNDRED COUNTRIES.
RECOGNIZING AND DECLARING THAT
WE NEED TO SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE
OUR DEPENDENCE ON SINGLE USE
PLASTICS.
WITH [inaudible]
THE PROPOSE PRODUCTION INCREASE
OF PLASTICS TO TO INCREASE BY
40%.
OF A IN THE NEXT FIVE TO TEN
YEARS WE SIMPLY CANNOT DO THIS
BY A RECYCLING AND INCINERATION
ALONE AND IN FACT INCINERATION.
IS SEEN BY MOST AS A VERY TOXIC
WAY TO GO BECAUSE OF THE THE
ADDITIVES AND AND ALL OF THE BY
PRODUCTS.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE SIMPLY
CANNOT RECYCLE OUR WAY OUT OF
WEEKS WE CANNOT INCINERATE OUR
WAY OUT OF THIS PROBLEM WE NEED
TO REDUCE.
THE PRODUCTION OF PLASTIC IT IS
THE ONLY WAY THAT WE CAN AS
STEVE SAID NOT HAVE TO INCREASE
THE SIZE OF OUR GARBAGE CANS NOT
HAVE TO CONTINUE TO EXPLORE OUR
WASTE.
I'M VERY EXCITED THAT CALIFORNIA
HAS A BILL THAT WILL BE HEARING
LATER TODAY THAT CAN HELP.
PROVIDE THE FRAMEWORK FOR THIS
MUCH NEEDED CHANGE.
I'M HAPPY TO BE BACK HERE AND
I'M HERE TO BE A RESOURCE FOR
YOU I THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU [inaudible]
MR.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
KELLY ASTOR --
I REPRESENT A VARIETY OF WASTE
RECYCLING TRADE GROUPS --
CHIEF AMONG THEM THE CALIFORNIA
REFUSE RECYCLING COUNCIL I
DEVOTED MUCH OF MY LIFE LAST
YEAR TO TRY TO GET THE WORD OUT
ON CHINA'S NATIONAL SORT OF WAS
TO IMPORT POLICY ON THE EFFECT
IT WAS HAVING ON THE INDUSTRY
HERE.
I'M DELIGHTED FOR THE HEARING
THAT YOU HAD TODAY AND THANK
BOTH CO CHAIRS OF FOR THAT I
THOUGHT A LOT OF VALUABLE
INFORMATION.
WAS DISTRIBUTED AND CONVERSATION
OCCURRED.
BOB I DON'T KNOW WHETHER TIME
ALLOW ME TO BE ATTENDING ALL THE
HEARING THIS AFTERNOON BUT I
ALSO WANT TO COMMUNICATE TO YOU
ARE.
ARE --
PLEASURE IN OFFERING SUPPORT FOR
YOUR SB. FIFTY FOUR ONE MIGHT
ORDINARILY THINK DID INDUSTRY
WOULD HAVE CONCERNS IN THAT IN
OUR FACILITIES ARE BUILT TO
OPERATE EFFICIENTLY WE ONE LOT
OF THROUGHPUT COMING THROUGH
THEM.
THE LESSON OF THE NATIONAL SORT
HAS BEEN FOR US THAT WE REALLY --
NEED HELP IN TERMS OF MARKET
DEVELOPMENT AND TO THE EXTENT
THAT YOU'RE LEGISLATION STEERS
THE ECONOMY AWAY FROM MATERIALS
THAT WE CANNOT WE CAN PROCESS
THAT WE CAN COLLECT THEM.
IF THEY HAVE NO HOME WERE
SITTING ON THEM THE IDEA THAT
OUR CONSUMERS OUR CUSTOMERS ARE
ARE MADE TO UNDERSTAND THAT
THEY'RE GONNA END UP.
LAND FILLING MATERIAL THAT THEY
THOUGHT WAS DESTINED FOR
RECYCLING IS A REAL PROBLEM FOR
US ALSO WE WE APPLAUD YOU ON
THAT AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY.
AND FOR YOUR ATTENTION TO THIS
ISSUE THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS COREY
CHAU LIBERAL AND I AM THE CO
FOUNDER OF REPURPOSE WE ARE THE
LEADING BRAND OF COMPOSTABLE
TABLEWARE IN THE RETAIL MARKET --
WE BRING PRODUCTS A COMMERCIAL
PRODUCTS LIKE WE DISCUSSED TODAY
TO CONSUMERS AT SHELF LEVEL WE
CREATED THE INDUSTRY AT PLACES
LIKE SAFEWAY ALBERTSONS --
AT WALMART AND ARE RAISING
AWARENESS AROUND ISSUES OF
SINGLE USE PLASTICS AND BRING
PEOPLE ALTERNATIVES IN THE
GROCERY AISLE THERE WAS NO
ALTERNATIVE THERE ARE ORGANIC
EGGS WHICH ARE GOING TO CATCH UP
BUT THERE WAS JUST THE THREE
CHINA DIXIE SOLO --
PLASTIC BRANDS OUT THERE WE
CREATED THAT MARKET AND WE ARE
NOW NOT NATIONWIDE LEADING
COMPANY WE ARE ALSO A CALIFORNIA
BASED COMPANY WE ARE IN LOS
ANGELES SIMPLY FIFTEEN PEOPLE.
WERE VERY MUCH SUPPORT THIS BILL
OBVIOUSLY WE FEEL THAT --
ARMADOS REVIEWS FIRST REPURPOSE
SECOND WITH THE CONCEPT THAT WE
SHOULD BE ELIMINATING SING THESE
PLASTICS AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE BUT
I THINK THE COMMITTEE.
HAS RIGHTFULLY RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE IS A NEED FOR SOME SINGLE
USE DISPOSABLES AND IF THEY
COULD BE MADE FROM GREENER
SOURCES AND DISPOSED OF AND
GREENER WAY SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR LETTING SPEAK AND WE
LOOK FOR DURING THE BILL THANK
YOU.
AND JUSTICE FOR FOLKS THE FOLKS
ARE HERE TO COMMENT ON THE BILL
SB.
FIFTY FOUR PLEASE WAIT UNTIL
THAT TIME COMES IT WILL JUST
TAKE COMMENT ON THE HEARING THAT
WE JUST FOUND.
ON PLASTIC SO.
GOOD MORNING I THINK IT'S STILL.
IN TIME.
GOOD AFTERNOON --
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN ALAN
INSURANCE STERN FOR THE HEARING
THIS MORNING AND OTHERS WHO
PARTICIPATED I THINK IT WAS VERY
INFORMATIVE --
THOSE OF US WHO HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON PLASTIC ISSUES FOR
MANY MANY YEARS NOW MYSELF SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY TWO ACTUALLY --
WENOW ARE ARE CAN OF SHOCKED
AND AMAZED THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE
DON'T ALREADY KNOW SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT WERE SHOWN HERE THIS
MORNING SO I THANK YOU.
FOR BRINGING THAT TO LIGHT --
IN ALSO FOR THEM I'M NOT GONNA
COMMENT OR A I AM I SAID I
SUPPORT YOUR BILL BUT I WON'T
COMMENT ON THAT AT THIS POINT
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I WANTED
TO MENTION HERE TODAY --
IT WAS A LITTLE BIT CONCERNED
ABOUT THE CALLING FROM VIENNA
WHO SPOKE SO.
WONDERFULLY ABOUT THEIR
INCINERATION SYSTEM AND WHERE IT
MAY BE STATE OF THE ART AND IT
MAY NOT BE PUTTING OUT A LOT OF
POLLUTION IT'S NOT AN ANSWER IF
YOU'RE GONNA GO TO THE CIRCULAR
ECONOMY.
AND I ANYTIME YOU INCINERATED
TAKE THOSE MOLECULES OUT OF PLAY
IT FORCES ADDITIONAL VIRGIN
PRODUCTION IF WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO BE PRODUCING SINGLE
USE ITEM SO SOURCE REDUCTION.
FOLLOWED BY THAT RECYCLING AS
MUCH AS IS POSSIBLE IN
COMPOSTING ARE THE ONLY WAYS TO
GO AND SO I WOULD STRONGLY URGE
YOU NOT UNDER ANY CIRCUMSTANCES
TO INCLUDE INCINERATION.
IN ANY KIND OF BILL THAT WOULD
COME OUT THAT HAS A GO.
OR A CIRCULAR ECONOMY SYSTEM
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
LAWYER MARIN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA GROSSES ATION --
GREAT HEARING --
PARTICULAR WANT TO TALK ABOUT --
THERE IS SOME A SECTION OF THE
TEST MY THEY HAD TO DO WITH FOOD --
AND SINGLE USE --
REDUCTION JUST WANT TO MAKE THE
VERY IMPORTANT DISTINCTION --
AS YOU CRAP POLICIES MOVING
FORWARD REGARDING TO SINGLE USE
PLASTIC IS IS JUST THE
DIFFERENCE THAT EXIST BETWEEN.
GROCERY PACKAGING VERSES MORE
RESTAURANT ORIENTED PACKAGING
AND YOU KNOW THE THINGS THAT WE
HAVE TO KEEP IN MIND WE WOULD
LIKE TO TELL PEOPLE THAT YOU
KNOW VERY OFTEN.
A RESTAURANT TYPE PACKAGING
LIVES FOR AN HOUR AT THE MOST
YOU PICK UP THE FOOD YOU EAT YOU
THREE STUFF AWAY YOU'RE A%
GROCERY STORE.
YOU'RE BUYING US UP IN THE THE
DELI BAKERY --
MEAT COUNTER YOU KNOW THAT THAT
PACKAGE AND IT'S EXPECTED TO
KEEP FOOD SAFE AND AND EDIBLE
FOR LONGER PERIODS OF TIME
BECAUSE PEOPLE YOU KNOW JUST
DON'T.
GO TO THE STORE AND EAT YOUR SIX
MUFFINS GENERALLY THE BEAR ABOUT
HOW BAD YOUR DAY'S WELL YEAH
EXACTLY EXACTLY SO --
JUST WOULD ASK THAT YOU KEEP
THAT --
THOUGHT IN MIND MOVING FORWARD --
AND JUST TO KNOW THAT YOU KNOW
WE'RE HERE AS GROCERS --
WE'VE DONE AT SEVERAL COMPANIES
WITH BOTH SUPPLIER AND RETAILER
TAKEN STEPS TO REDUCE --
THE TIED THE NUMBER OF WASTE OF
THE AMOUNT OF WASTE ISSUES
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY AS WAS POINTED
OUT EARLIER EIGHT HELPS OUR
BOTTOM LINE.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME WE ALWAYS
HAVE TO KEEP IN MIND THAT THAT
SAFETY --
AND FOOD LONGEVITY IS OF THE
UTMOST IMPORTANCE OUR FOLKS AND
JUST ASK YOU KEEP THAT IN MIND A
WITHIN LEGISLATION FORTUNE
THANKS SO MUCH THANK YOU.
OKAY LAST BUT NOT LEAST IN THE
MORNING GOING TO THE BILLS THANK.
CHAIRMAN I'M HI SAM BURNHAM WITH
THE NATIONAL STORAGE OF ACTION
COUNCIL OR A SPIN OFF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PRODUCTS OR TO
COUNSEL.
AND WE ADVOCATE FOR CIRCULAR
ECONOMY.
I WANTED TO REITERATE WHAT --
MISS GORDON SAID ABOUT SOURCE
REDUCTION IS SO IMPORTANT HAVE
IT FIRST --
MATERIAL LIMITATION IS GOING TO
BE IMPORTANT WE HAVE A LOT OF
PLASTICS THAT WERE COMING IN AS
WE CAN DO NOTHING WITH.
AND HAVING THEM IN THE SYSTEM IS
IS VERY DEBT TO POSSIBILITY
POSSIBLY FOR WHAT'S THAT LEFT IN
THE PACKAGING AND I DID WANNA A
BUILD UP WHICH THE WOMAN JUST
SAID ABOUT THE INCINERATION.
I WAS IN BELGIUM AND SPOKE AT
THE EPR INTERNATIONAL CONFERENCE
FOR PACKAGING IN.
TWENTY TEN AT THAT POINT THEY
HAD ALREADY BEEN IN PLACE FOR
TWENTY YEARS WITH ANY PAIR
SYSTEM FOR PACKAGING.
AND THEY HAD TO COUPLE
GENERATION FROM THE ECONOMIC
GROWTH --
AND THEY'D REDUCED INCINERATION
414% TO FOUR I DON'T WANT THE
COMMITTEE TO GET THE IMPRESSION
THAT JUST BECAUSE WE MIGHT GO
WITH AN EXTENDED PRETTIES
RESPONSIBILITY MODEL THAT DOES
NOT NECESSARILY MEAN INCREASES
FEDERATION FACT IT SHOULD AND
IMPLIED DECREASING INCINERATION --
AND I'D ALSO LIKE TO INVITE YOU
ALL TO THE GRAND OPENING OF THE
AQUA FILL PLANT WHICH IS
PROBABLY ONE OF THE FIRST NEW
INFRASTRUCTURE PLANTS AND THE
STATE RECENTLY --
IT'S GOING TO BE IN WOODLAND AND
AND A COUPLE OF MONTHS IT'LL BE
OPEN AND IT'S A DIRECT RESULT OF
YOUR VOTE ON THE CARPET BILL AB
ELEVEN FIFTY EIGHT A TWO YEARS
AGO. TO IMPROVE THAT IF YOUR
SYSTEM SO.
THE JOBS THE INFRASTRUCTURE CAN
CALM WHEN WE ACTUALLY PASSED THE
RIGHT LEGISLATION THAT'S FAIR
ACROSS THE BOARD AND IS CIRCULAR
THAT PER PLANT IS A COMPLETELY
CIRCULAR ECONOMY APPROACH WHERE
IT'S GOING TO PRODUCE FLUFF.
ACTUALLY GONNA GO TO SOLVE ANY
EVENTUALLY THEY'LL BUILD THE
PLANT I IN GEORGIA THAT WILL
THEN MAKE IT INTO A PURE PELLETS
A GOING TO KELLY SLATER SURFWEAR
AND IT'S A CELL MCCARTY HANDBAGS
I CAN GO OVER AND OVER AND OVER
AGAIN AND THAT'S WHAT WHERE WE
NEED TO STRIVE. FOR SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU ON
THIS AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE HEARING THANK YOU THANK YOU
I MEAN THERE'S NO THERE'S NO
QUESTION THAT --
AND THAT YOU KNOW NO MATTER HOW
STATE OF THE ART THERE
INCINERATION TECHNIQUES MAYBE
IT'S AN ABSOLUTE SUB PAR WAY OF
HANDLING THIS PROBLEM --
THE SAD THING IS THAT A LOT OF
THAT STUFF THAT FOLKS THINK.
IS BEING RECYCLED WHEN THEY
THROW IN THEIR BINS HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES AND THAT ACTUALLY
BEING RECESS INCINERATED UNDER
MUCH LESS ENVIRONMENTALLY
FRIENDLY STANDARDS IN INDIANA IN
INDONESIA AND ELSEWHERE SO.
THIS IS WHY WE'RE TRYING TO
ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM BEEN SB
FIFTY FOUR SO WITH THAT LET ME
ADJOURNED --
THIS JOINT HEARING OF THE
NATURAL RESOURCES AND A QUOTE
FROM A QUALITY COMMITTEES.